two
hello hello we are extremely late sorry
about that
um it's all Dan's fault don't look at me
I'm just kidding Dan I know you try
you're I'm kidding no I'm agreeing with
you we had Tech issues but it's not
Dan's fault I know that we had uh
uh what happened
well every what happened is we've been
uh testing to make sure that crackle
issue doesn't come back all morning for
about three hours and then you walked
into the building and it started
happening my body runs interference dude
and then and then one of our uh power
battery backups started beeping and was
being overloaded for some reason
literally within like 60 seconds of
Ethan entering the building so good
stuff as Dan was trying to resolve that
just started like going beep beep beep
like really uh frantically but we're
here we're here we made it
and thank you guys for being patient
being here we're gonna have a great Show
sponsored by stabs.com
we love staff yes
feels like I've been gone forever man I
took uh I took one day off I feel like
I've been gone for freaking eternity I
just missed Monday right
we did Friday's episode yes that's right
just Monday and then on the weekend me
and Ila went to Laguna Beach
before
um Eli gets preggers
and uh it was fun
uh we just took it easy low-key just
hang it out in the room and doing room
service we brought the dogs it was fun
one thing that was interesting
is that we were down in the lobby there
was like a little cafe there
and we ran into none other than Bryce
Hall Getting Coffee
at the same establishment
he saw me come in
and uh
he said what up he was very polite I
will say I will give him you know he was
actually very nice he we shook hands
he was there for some charity thing
he was with this guy I forgive I don't
know this guy's name he's like a tall
dude who like make he's like
he's a tall guy and he's like oh okay
and he goes tall guy I've seen these
videos he goes hey baby you want to make
out with me and they make out in like
hot tubs and he's like I don't know it's
you know do you know who anyone does
that ring a bell here no tall dude who
makes out with people in hot tubs I know
it sounds it's very popular somehow
here it is wait is this it
see that was easy to find yeah here he
is Tommy
Tommy Untold
you guys probably recognize him
um hold on let me find his Tick Tock
account because I was I've been trying
to figure out
his name
you guys find Tommy Untold anyway I have
nothing to say about him
hey I just recognize him that's all
yeah thank you oh he's pretty popular 11
million followers okay Tommy Untold the
Apparently you've just told it all said
it all
wait how many followers does Bryce Hall
have he's gotta have more than that
right follow me Bryce Hall's like big
daddy
24 million oh and standing for Selena he
knows what he's doing
wow
yeah he was really nice actually
and funnily enough we had invited him on
the show previously
and uh we asked if he was vaccinated and
then he kind of ghosted us
or he's like yeah I'm vaccinated I was
like can you send um
can you just send an image of your
vaccination record and then he ghosted
us
well the first thing he said to me when
I saw him in line was I'm actually
vaccinated now so if you want to have me
on the show we can do it and I said that
sounds good
so we should so I'm reaching out to
Bryce Hall
who we were standing for a little bit
because he was going to fight someone I
didn't like what was that about he
fought Austin McBroom oh it didn't go
very well no that one didn't but right
okay but you know what
I do want to know if he ever got paid
I'm gonna message him right now I know
it's not the most compelling content but
I'm gonna DM him on Instagram oh he
doesn't follow me on Instagram I'm gonna
DM him on Twitter
how did we reach him before Bryce
rice
you tweeted publicly last time okay oh
we follow each other on Twitter okay
here we go hey Bryce let's set it up
there it is
I think that'd be a fun desk don't you
guys
there it is just leave your buddy at at
home for this one no offense to him
he's not invited
all right anyway
[Applause]
also want to give a shout out to our
first lore video this series is to
initiate God damn it hit YouTube
on Monday
and uh I'm very happy you know I'm very
excited I'm gonna upvote it because if
you don't like your own videos who does
who will you know
and I'm very excited for it I hope you
guys enjoyed it it's on the main Channel
this is
thank you Carlos
um this is the first in a series that
we're going to do every week
and I think it's gonna be awesome for
both new uh viewers and old members
alike I'm thinking the next one
love we're thinking Dan the introducing
Dan the producer
love is not here
but that's what I was thinking like
origin stories of Dan you know I'll do
everybody but Dan of course is the
originator and
a lot of people probably haven't seen
Old Dan sword love so I think that'll be
great so thank you I'm looking forward
to that yes yes
ah
excuse me
how was your guys's weekend
anything interesting
not really
it's nice to just have a weekend just to
chill for a little bit you boxed at all
this weekend
uh yeah I did I had a workout session
with amaranth actually she came to my
gym that was fun oh that's nice how did
she do she good yeah she'd be good she's
still new but uh she did good she did
good you think she's got a shot yeah
definitely more than a shot
she could be a cadeta you think she's
gonna win her match absolutely okay
you're putting money down right putting
money on her five thousand dollars
you're betting me right now all the
money to my name really bet me just to
prove that you I I think amarath is a
fighter but bet me all right I'll bet
you 100 100
just to make it interesting wait who's
she fighting is it yodeling Haley no no
okay good because we I stand yodeling
Haley
I'm not exactly sure who she's fighting
it's not in the Creator clash it's a
different event does Haley yodel
[Music]
that is a fantastic question I don't
believe I've seen her yell once
okay
for the record but we don't hold that
against her anyone else
something interesting oh I know what
happened I know you and uh Dan you and
Ian had an interesting weekend didn't
you
yeah it was interesting it was
interesting we uh
we made a run at the Oscars we made we
we charge the the red carpet yeah
were you guys able to get in
we have a whole video about it I mean do
we want to get into this right now well
I think so the Oscars is obviously a Hot
Topic right now it's a lot of uh lots of
people are buzzing about the Oscars yes
the 57th Oscars
2023. keep my flight name out your
[__] no Will Smith is indeed banned
from the Oscars for 10 years or
something like that
that sounded horrible
uh there's the big Winners
congratulations to everything everywhere
all at once one best picture
and one like everything and everywhere
congratulate the Stars the winners did
you get to ask them questions and having
been on the biggest podcast in the world
surely you had press access
[Music]
you're just gonna have to wait and see
you're trying to get me to spoil this
masterpiece that we shot this weekend
but okay they had their potentially did
interview the biggest stars of the
evening Brendan Frasier oh Brendan
Frazier who actually uh oh
one uh for the whale
yes indeed and actually what's
interesting about the whale
I keep seeing like Brendan Fraser are
you so good the well the way well but
then like I was like okay should I see
this movie and I want to read reviews
and people do not like this movie I find
that interesting people as in uh critics
there seems to be like a unanimous
decision amongst critics and audience
alike that it is a mediocre film and so
I Wonder has there ever been so much
hype for a performance in a like
mediocre film or bad even
find that interesting don't you I think
everyone is here for the return of
Brenda Frazier because it's been down
about hell yeah I'm down for it oh the
audience
I like Brandon Frazier too but what's
what's you know what's what's follow-up
to this one
all right the mammoth not like it
The Walrus you know you gotta bring back
the mummy is that mommy yeah this man is
not ready for the mummy brother bring it
back bring it back Tarzan and uh Dwayne
The Rock Johnson is a much bigger star
than he was when he uh did his turn as
The Scorpion King in that series and I
want to see The Scorpion King make a
comeback too The Scorpion King wins this
time no question hey Ian uh you you've
seen the whale uh yes I didn't like it
that much I did not like it
why'd you say that twice I don't know
you take it away Zach what did I think
of the way I did not like it okay
um Zach for Ian did you like the film
you are bullying me
okay all right if you don't want to get
involved just say so I got those cheeks
all right uh yeah I had lunch
okay whatever don't have to make fun of
his weight again he has a massive penis
oh all right thank you that's what the
whale is a referencing did you think
that Brendan Frazier had an uh an
award-winning performance uh yeah yeah I
I thought he was he was very good I
thought the movie was
that was it he was good but the movie
wasn't a movie I would ever want to
watch again ever right
um but that's kind of common there are a
lot of nominees that
get buzzed for the for the performance
in the movies aren't necessarily huge so
what what was his performance he's just
like Brett Frazier as a fat guy
you know he does the thing he's crying
he's doing facial expressions you know
he's acting yeah he acts like Angela
scenes that are little
comical a little over the top in my
opinion
I don't even know what it's about a
reclusive English teacher suffering from
severe obesity attempts to reconnect
with his estranged teenage daughter for
one last chance to Redemption
Ian didn't you say didn't you tell me
that when you saw it in theaters like
the entire theater was like sobbing like
that's all unconsolably and you
mentioned that there was like serious
tears going on uh I don't know if that
was me oh okay maybe somebody else told
me were they crying because he was fat
or because sobbing in the theater well
they were crying because he's fat or
because he was like a sad movie it's
it's sad but the movie kind of why I
didn't like it is because you can tell
that the writer is writing to make you
cry like over and over on purpose and it
felt a little disingenuous to me all
right I found out recently it was a uh a
play before it was a movie I didn't know
that
all right
there's one like mukbang scene where
they have this is like going and he's
slamming chicken and pizza and it's
meant to be really intense but with the
music swelling and I'm like you're
trying to make me sad but it's like a
Nick ocado video with like a score and I
was just like I want Nick acoto to do
that on a video because it would elevate
it to like Oscar level dude I don't
think this director knows what we and
gen Z are used to seeing on YouTube
because that is not going to shock any
of us until you've seen NECA slam a
table with 20 [__] half eaten
cheeseburgers and cry you have not seen
the whale yeah we've been very blessed
in terms of our version yeah and I bet
you he didn't even lean over and show
his [__]
[Applause]
and you know what's interesting about
blow holes no the air that comes out of
them also stinks did you know that
blowhole air stinks uh yeah I mean I
guess it's that makes sense if you go
whale watching when if you are lucky
enough to see a whale and they come up
for air it really is a strong and
unpleasant odor much like the air that
comes out of nicocado's [__]
right now
[Music]
shout out I think Nick must be the real
well though because like he is already
mukbang and crying
you know
really
should I say button but it's too too
late
you really gonna hit me crickets act
like you're better than this
okay Zachary
he called me Zachary dude
oh well yeah let's sew anyway regarding
the Oscars let's just see because again
us being
the biggest podcast in the world right
also I mean uh related we just hit a
billion views on our podcast Channel
let's [__] go
now there's a lot of channels with the
billion views but I think for a podcast
that's pretty crazy
it's massive it's awesome can I get an
amen on a business thank you how are you
dude thanks bro Hallelujah
so I'm just saying we're a pretty big
deal amen
and so with all that being said
um we sent our best and brightest Dan
our producer and uh and our switcher and
our comedic uh brains
um out to the Oscars to interview the
Stars so let's just go ahead and roll it
it's me Mr Oscar on Hollywood's biggest
knife I um I look stupid I look like
Ferrero Rocher
I look like a condom rapper Dan I look
like the foil they put to keep the space
station safe from radiation or something
I don't think I can do this I don't
think so you look so good it's gonna be
okay buddy I can't do this no people
love people are gonna love it people are
gonna love it you look so good look at
you we look similar right
Mr Oscar is back we're feeling good
there's there's been so much incredible
Cinema memorable Cinema everyone has
seen the Banshees of innish year and I
could quote it so Dan what movies do you
think are gonna win at the Academy
Awards somewhere in the region of two
dozen-ish Oscars tonight for box office
Jim for Avatar 2 the way of water what
about the other
what other movies ever everything
everywhere all at once people say it's
as a shoe-in for winning best picture
the best picture is a shoe out because
shoes are out on the planet Pandora
because the navi do not
okay you're done you're done
Mr Oscar
yourself
don't film that stop this looks cool
eyes on me Ron Hey eyes on me eyes on me
over here Dan Dan you have to be the
cameraman get over here stop I look like
one of those guys that stands still
I can go stand still for a bit because I
need to make my money back on this
jacket you guys want to do an interview
interview
okay no that's all good I've heard that
one before I'm Swiss
leave me alone you guys want to do an
interview
nope
no no one wants to speak to me
I thought it was special
I'm more than an Emmy
I'm more than a Golden Globe I got that
at least independent Spirit award sag
award
yeah
writer's Guild producers Guild a TV
movie award I thought I was more than
that
and that's acting that's acting Mr Oscar
knows a thing or two about acting
dude best International Film When Doves
flew by uh Pablo Sandoval do you think
he has a chance
When Doves I didn't get to see that one
yet your favorite movie of the year
um John Van Damme movies old school
it's had a big year the dove flew with
Kristoff Sandoval you think they they
have a chance of winning
maybe for International Film do you
think Ulrich Nielsen might pull it out
for Colwell 91. I
guess possible I'm honestly not super
he might bring home the gold though it's
there's a chance there's a chance yes
midnight Moonlight with Andrea sultin
you think there's a chance she might win
for best actress
um I haven't seen that picture but I
heard I heard her performance is good
every movie I've asked people about I
made it up I don't know what's nominated
frankly I don't care
all right oh yeah get right in there
you want a closer shot
here get a little
that's good really get in the gold yeah
yeah no problem she's vibing out she's
vibing
[Music]
forget foot traffic like
who cares
you're right
damn stop shooting the Scientology
why is the L Ron Hubbard thing I've
lived in La my whole life I never really
come down here and it's just all this
stuff It's So Glamorous that's the whole
point but they suck you in and then
I don't want you to know who Zeno is
okay it's asking if I'm curious
and I'm curious okay it seems we've hit
a wall or a cage
they're not let there must be a mistake
it's me Mr Oscar
you got where should I enter I have to
be on stage I got like three hours left
so where's the entrance for the Oscar
Miss I'm Mr Oscar so where where do I
get in where should I go
unvine there's this back entrance okay
got it cool you okay thank you officer
appreciate it he said Vine which is it's
kind of in the opposite direction of the
venue no pictures please no pictures
they don't want me to get too close to
the theater mainly because they don't
want a mob situation they don't want a
lot of crowding that's when Mr Oscar
shows up I've got security team over
there
um yep hey guys waving they're not
putting on the makeup I inhaled a lot of
fumes
a little dizzy
we could go right on stage if we wanted
to but you know what I want to show you
guys the real Hollywood as a local I
know all the good spots watch out for
the garbage there don't step on that oh
this is where all the good
this is where all the good [__] is oh my
God there's there's there's [__] in that
bucket you know that's uh oh man Colin
Farrell he's such a prankster there's
there's watch out for the [__]
blur that there's more [__]
no it's not I think I want to nominate
my
matadox Rabbi Bill Clinton thank you
everybody yes it is
wow
you gotta yell Dan
you gotta yell into his microphone wow
Dan didn't want to yell into his
microphone you pissed him off
that guy's everywhere he's like Bloody
Mary now we know who's [__] all over
the floor because that guy's walking
around don't film the back of my head
either my bald Cap's not on properly
I kind of want to go I'm too big time
for this [__] dude why am I operating
the camera I'm the [__] producer I
just want to go [__] L Ron Hubbard
Museum dude stop that's enough Dan
come on dude it's not a very
professional Dan
okay that's unnecessary El Dan
everyone's gonna say Elder why are you
running away Jesus I don't need Dan I
can hold the camera myself sure my
hand's shaking like a [__] astronaut
simulation I'll go make something of
myself it's Hollywood it's Hollywood the
land of dreams land of opportunity I can
do whatever I want
[Music]
let's see
I got it we got it Steph broke him off
as you can see wow
nothing but respect as usual for the H3
podcast down at the Oscars
and then Dan of course L Dan Hubbard
couldn't get over Scientology did you
get a chance to go in there and and uh
you know I did really interesting they
made me take this little test and they
had like this little machine yeah it was
very cool and apparently I've got a lot
of problems a lot I could have told you
that right yeah but they have the
solution and it's like really affordable
like payment plan I think it's really
cool statement plan well yeah I mean
it's all it's a lot up front they put
you but if you put it you know Finance
it all right it's okay though I got like
a 28 APR or something like that okay
sounds like Dan had a fruitful
experience yeah there it is it's great
Ian I think I know what the problem was
you were TR you were saying hey I'm the
Oscar you should have said hey I'm with
H3 podcast I'll let you back there for
sure then I would have been arrested you
think you would have been yeah maybe
okay well um
nice to see we get respect finally
absolutely
it's nice to see that you know after all
this time
but thank you guys excellent on the
field recording thank you thank you did
you uh watch Hollywood's big night
news Hollywood's big night did you watch
did I watch the Oscars yeah I just
watched your guys's uh coverage
did you watch it
I I watch it every year I love the
Oscars I watched Tim heidecker's on
cinema at the cinema Oscar special that
they do every year I was playing the
bindings of Isaac okay that's good too
it'd be totally honest with you guys
that's fun yeah it's a fun game so um
I want to say Ian that was fantastic
thank you and I also you know Ian you're
you're very funny you're very talented
you know
Ian came to me and he said I don't even
know if I want to post it I don't think
it's funny
and I shook him I said idiot
damn it
it's very funny and everybody loves you
funny thank you funny do you feel do you
feel like after watching it with the
with everybody that it felt better to
you or
yeah it was fine yeah yeah it was good
yeah I know that feeling though I used
to make videos like that and it's so
hard to know if it's funny or not when
you get close to it so close to it
yeah but there it is it's funny
I appreciate that thank you sir
so um congratulations to all the winners
especially Brendan Frazier who portrayed
a fat guy
now I don't know what's going on before
that person
people start going oh well if you're
black you gotta get a black guy well
that'd be a little [__] crazy not to
get it like I don't think they do in
life face in Hollywood anymore
but like getting a gay person to play a
gay person right so why is it that they
hired Brendan Frazier when I was
available to play the whale when already
am a whale why is it that you're hiring
skinny actors like Brandon Frazier to
play morbidly obese ones when there's
perfectly good morbidly obese people out
there why is that
you know I'm talking about fat rights us
fatties have [__] rights
I've had enough discrimination from
skinny [__] actors taking my goddamn
fat given
given my goddamn fat god-given rights
okay
[Music]
and furthermore
I believe that us fatties need to come
together not in one space because that
would be structurally dangerous but like
um
uh like metaphorically and we need to
campaign
for better treatment
fat rolls for fat people period you're
saying he did Fat Face he did Fat Face
and it's a shame that you know in 2023
we're still doing that kind of
disgusting
abuse
of Human Rights it is [__] up yeah
that's all I'll say about that shame on
you Brendan Fraser
shame on you
[Music]
I would have been great in that role oh
so Excel be fat whatever dude that's my
whole life sad and fat
oh oh fat ugly and stupid that's it
uh English teacher he's an English
teacher I majored in English literature
uh I'm fat I'm fat and sad and I read
books [__] that [__] not impressed fat
ugly and stupid
thank you for hearing me out at least
I think I have a point
um
one thing I wanted to mention over the
weekend I was watching
dude True Crime is taking over it's like
80 of what's on TV
which is fine for me because I love this
[__]
but um
there's a new or I don't know if it's
new but it's the first time I saw it's
called
uh investigation discovery so I guess
it's Discovery Channel's spin on True
Crime
and they did
a three-part series on Jared Fogle
and this is probably
the craziest [__] documentary I've
ever seen mean ela's jaw was on the
floor the whole time like it kept
getting worse and worse and crazier and
I did not know the whole story of Jared
Fogle
but
I mean if you can stomach some kinds of
disturbing content around this it's
definitely worth watching because I was
like what the [__] dude Jared has gone
full Joker he had like a whole
infrastructure of like
pitos like um
his manager was supplying him videos
the manager's wife okay had two
daughters who she helped him hide
cameras in their rooms their own
daughters for content
their own [__] kids
bro
I I I just my jaw was on the [__]
ground this Jared is like a monster
it was insane I didn't want you watched
it I started it after you mentioned it I
watched the first uh episode and some of
the second it was insane dude it gets
crazier every [__] scene it was
crazier and crazier and crazier
I I can't believe I have all those
recordings oh so
the woman who put him away was some
she's just some random woman
she met him years before
and Jared made some random aside to her
out of nowhere about how God I just love
teenage girls or something really weird
like that they were at a game and he
said I love Middle School girls
just an aside
and she's like what the [__] she was so
taken aback by it
and I think she tried to complain and
mention it and it was just you know
it was like almost like a figment of Her
Imagination he's like did this really
happen
and so over the years it was three years
she befriended him
and
she pretended
to share his interests
and she recorded like hundreds of hours
of conversations with him
over three [__] years
and dude it so like it's all
recorded like his deepest darkest
thoughts and desires like I've never
heard this level of insight into someone
like that
and This Woman's like a hero dude I
don't know how she did it because like
she had kids she said she would go into
other room when she talked to him she
never talked to him from her kids and he
was starting to ask her to hide cameras
in her room to record she's her kids
bro it was [__]
and I was just I couldn't believe it
I could not [__] believe it why did
she do it for three years she was
telling the FBI that and she's like yo
what the [__] they wouldn't act all
right for three [__] years
they didn't do [__] and Jared continued
to [__] molest people crazy she had
like real explicit uh recordings too
talking about stuff he did overseas and
stuff he did here but they were just
like him talking about it isn't enough
him
explicitly saying his crimes and his
desires and asking her to do illegal
[__]
and and they didn't do [__] [__] and
you know what's interesting she was
after three years like yo FBI this is
[__] crazy y'all need to do something
because she's like I can't do this
anymore I'm I am dissolving as a person
my I'm becoming like crushed
and um when she told the FBI she was
going to go public you know what they
did they subpoenaed they [__] um
raided her house and stole all her [__]
not Jared's they stole her computer they
gag ordered her not to talk about it and
so um that was their response to go
after her
and finally the story only broke when
this woman went public to some
journalist about it and she sent all
these tapes she had to some journalist
um and because the FBI wasn't [__]
doing anything and he was just straight
up molesting people going on world tours
country tours going to schools
all around kids all the time
dude it was crazy bro I have never seen
anything like it
absolutely nuts
I if you're if you can handle that kind
of stuff definitely [__] watch that
it was crazy
executive director of fogo's
philanthropy organization sent Images Oh
yes so so that was his manager or his
manager the director of his foundation
was also somehow uh prolific and
horrific predator
and he was
grooming people for Fogle and then
sending him images
wow and then this was the weird this was
the craziest part so the director
of his organization
married this woman she had two daughters
and they said her mom was normal
Christian she was like a hardcore
Christian God-fearing lady
and then when she married fogle's
director I think his name was Mitchell I
don't remember his last name
she totally changed
and then they were encouraging them to
like drink in the house
and to like explore their sexuality at a
young age
and she like totally changed and was all
[__] crazy and then they found out
that she was working with this dude
Russell they had cameras in their
bathroom in their [__] room
they told about one time her mom dude
this is [__] Chris I'm sorry if this
is like trigger warning I just was so
shocked by this
to their mom one time
put a [__] sex toy
on the bed and was like hey you should
go experiment with that and she had a
camera set up
her own mom
[__] insane a hidden camera her old
mom dude I I just I I could not [__]
believe this [__] and this woman
apparently according to them
um was a normal God-fearing Christian
before all before she met this dude
Russell
holy [__] I I can't tell you my jaw was
on the ground the whole time dude
and what's interesting is there was like
apparently
a lot of complaints about Fogo being
inappropriate that were never looked
into over the years
I mean not to mention the FBI had all
these [__] documents for three years
and didn't do anything pretty incredible
stuff
[__] crazy
someone said how old were the kids they
were
not teenagers they were not even maybe
they were at the oldest one was like 13
maybe at most at but again it was like
over three years so they were they were
young
and a text message obtained during the
investigation of Fogle he wrote to an
undisclosed recipient I'll pay you oh
God bro he said he had they had this in
writing
I'll pay you big for a 14 or 15 year old
because it's what I crave he added
of his preference the younger the better
LOL
Bro Jared [__] folo and at the height
of his power he was worth 15 million
dollars apparently so he was like
and you know what's interesting too he
he didn't he'll take he would take boys
or girls like it was just about like
having a young person it wasn't about
like gender or anything he was just a
[__] monster dude
crazy [__] dude
yeah in the first phone call I think
they shown documentary he's talking
about a 10 year old
it's insane dude it's it's [__] I
cannot emphasize how crazy this [__] is
I had no idea the document is called um
investigating a monster or catching a
monster Jared Fogle I think it's called
Uh Jared from Subway catching a monster
Jay from Subway catching a monster on
Discovery for Subway is thrilled with
the title yeah I was just I was thinking
like I hope companies learn not to put
all their branding into one person now
after that they created that monster
dude yeah Jared from Subway that was it
that's how they referred to him the
whole documentary Jared from Subway they
said Subway like a bajillion times
so I'm going to keep an eye on them
right but it seems like there was
definitely a lot of Flow from
Progressive flows yeah look out oh flow
we got our eyes on you Gekko we got our
eyes on here something seriously wrong
there
wait do you Josie did you not know about
this she said no the actual sub Gateway
guy did you not know about Jared Fogle
it was a big story but it was a long
time ago wait so wait Lena you didn't
know about Jared Fogle no I knew about
him okay I mean I didn't know
until just 3
there's like a lot of people in bed
saying the same thing the guy from
Subway they didn't know about this no
they don't know a lot of people whoa I
really had no idea you didn't know that
I didn't even really know who Jared I
guess you guys are a little bit younger
because I guess it's for do you
recognize him no oh [__]
so then it should be even really
interesting to you so yeah when I was I
guess in my early 20s
this guy was like a [__] National
Treasure a national hero his face was
everywhere this man he lost like 150
pounds from eating Subway
really yes that's his story I think I
think it's I think it's relatively true
from what I can tell he was walking and
he was eating like two
six inch sandwiches a day and he lost a
bunch of weight and so Subway's like yo
let's [__] get this guy
and they started this insane media blitz
where they rebranded Subway as like a
healthy
fast food option and it was
probably one of the most successful
marketing campaigns ever I mean this guy
had like a foundation he was touring the
United States going to schools talking
to kids about health and [__]
I think that everybody my age and
everybody alive at the time who was you
know consuming media knew who this guy
was
went around
schools that's all he did yeah that's
all he wanted to do I bet that was his
job but yeah oh
wow well that is a crazy story I'm going
to be watching look at this Jared Fogle
speaks from prison quote I royally
screwed up oh yeah
bro the [__] is that it
is this really what he looks like now
Jesus
do you think he would have gone caught
if it wasn't for that woman
he went undercover and befriended him I
don't know man if I don't know if it is
it's probably inevitably somebody would
have accused him of something but he
probably would have done a lot more
damage years he would have had years
more
of abusing people this woman is a
[__] hero dude I always think about
these people that they're so dumb to be
so blatant but then I realized like it's
only the dumb and blatant people that
get caught the smart people are probably
still out there [__] right we're just
quieting thought it's so so [__] up
Epstein was like the most prolific one
and he I mean the thing is
I think
I think Fogel thought he was Untouchable
which is weird because he's just a
[__] Subway guys the subway guy
he's hot [__]
mascot World his necklace wow what's
going on there that clown Ronald ain't
got [__] on Jared
oh yeah but in the in the documentary
started getting fat again
at Subway was they were freaked out
because he was gaining weight not
because he was you know molesting kids
right yeah yo he's getting fat again
that's the problem Tom Segura tells a
story he did a big commercial early in
his career where he did a commercial
with Jared Fogle and he tells the story
he went into his trailer and then
Jared's like hey you want to order a
pizza and they had a [__] Pizza
together
[__] the subway [__] how long is he in
jail for this [__] guy I think he got
his ass beat in prison too or something
which is good I prove
hopefully forever
let's see he is I think someone said
yeah 15 years eight months 15. people go
to [__] jail for their own for
stealing a Snickers right
oh yeah he was so this oh he has kids he
has two kids now in the documentary they
don't
they don't mention the kids I I don't
know if he ever did anything to his own
kids they never talk about it but they
almost gloss over the fact that he had
two kids and a wife
um
and I was like oh my God I hope that
he never did anything to them
he divorced his wife pretty early right
I remember I think she left him when he
went to jail no right
[Music]
maybe he was in that uh Adam Sandler
movie Jack and Jill he was oh looks like
that as placement yeah yeah of course
Adam Sandler bless his heart is the
biggest [__] chill in Hollywood like
it's crazy dunkaccino dude
they did like a montage of Jared and how
famous he
Missy wait where did you see that in the
in the document oh you guys watched it
together yeah yeah like I knew he was
big of course I've always heard of him
but I didn't know it was to that degree
it was wild seeing that I was eating
Subway back then boy I was like let's go
to Subway oh my God
I wasn't eating that healthy [__] there
but I wanted it five dollar footlongs
you all know what it is
five dollar footlongs are long gone man
thanks Joe Brandon
oh Subway sounds
if you listen closely you can hear
you can hear The Whispers of Fogel
through the halls of Subway Robert
here's Jared fogle's mug shot before
being transferred hey [__] idiot
loser [__] up your ass gets beat in
prison
evil
just evil man
[__] you know
but I want to see if he got his ass beat
in prison
I remember reading some incarceration
let's see judge Pratt agreed but yada
yada yada
he arrived at prison
he was transferred yeah he was yeah he
got his ad oh here March 2016 Fogo was
assaulted by another inmate
the attack left Fogo debris no swollen
face and scratches on his neck
where's the shame that was 2015. yeah
2017 he was reportedly beaten by another
inmate
um
yeah
yo so there it is so he's having a good
time in prison he's having a good time
amongst friends
crazy huh
there it is I recommend watching it if
you could uh stomach that kind of [__]
but yeah
draw dropping [__] man
so uh who wants Subway
how do you like your sandwich Jared
well
I like my sandwich
medium rare
medium rare what's a medium rare best it
can be I like my sandwich virgin no oil
I like the veal
oh yeah you guys have veal here
Avery armad just sent me that he was a
boss in the South Park video game
that's insane it doesn't surprise me he
was huge he was huge well there was that
old South Park episode he was in
he was everywhere man
uh Wendy what do you think about Jared
from Subway Wendy Williams
no what else do you think
died
died what else
you've got them they're long you show
them I want to clap Wendy
clap if you think she
if you've ever wanted to kill somebody
there's my girl Wendy that's why I eat
Quiznos bro there was a Subway there was
a sandwich War happening at the time
Quiznos versus Subway Quiznos lost that
Quiznos lost big time it's just
Christmas Even around anymore I don't
think so
I actually liked Quiznos but it didn't
really have the same swaggy kind of pedo
uh backing us what they really missed
was a prolific predator for a
spokesperson because I was even the
quizzes even have a mascot like who's
the Quiznos I think it's the Pope
hahaha
no because then they would have been
able to stand on equal footing um I'm on
their website they do exist find a
quiznosis Quiznos was the original q a
mascot they have 238 in the whole
country okay so they're killing it
somewhere they see it was I I always
felt it was better than Subway what the
[__] I just searched Quiznos mascot
oh I remember that oh yeah they had
these crazy [__] up commercials open
that oh my God I remember the thing the
quiznosa see that's dude y'all really
under Subway one that's a crazy way to
advertise so how many Quiznos are there
this guy's scared looking in the
pedophile
[Music]
this was a this is not most 2006
keep it going if this came out today 100
gold star it would get whoops remember
this is on TV you're not seeing this on
National yeah prime time this that on
Tick Tock is different
yeah they definitely went in a certain
direction they were losing money and
they ran out of money for an ad so
that's all they can afford there are 20
000 Subways in the United States how
many Quiznos are there uh 237 this
Google Search says yeah
L and there's no there's none in LA
right well jizzling Maxwell might be
available for gigs if uh
I don't think quiz Lane
quiz Lane dude there you go that's nice
that's nice Quiznos was also the
original Q Anon they're the queue oh
what other prolific child predators are
at large that would be available to work
with Quiznos
um the Verizon guy
oh don't say that he went over to Sprint
no I'm kidding no yeah he didn't better
be kidding I'm kidding that's a joke
that's a joke we don't accuse people of
such horrible things there was some
crazy [__] that he went over though to
Sprint after [__] Judas yeah
um that's a power move they must have
offered him a lot of cheddar you got
that bag exactly all right enough let's
talk about our lovely sponsor stamps and
we've got a lot of show left to do a lot
I mean geez we haven't even scratched
the surface of this mat this monstrous
show yeah I was reviewing the doc this
morning and I I had the thought that our
top of the show section is about three
and a half to four hours of material I'm
just gonna I'm gonna scroll through here
and pick out my faves and maybe we're
probably gonna have a lot left over for
uh let's let's Friday
let's work for us
thank you to our lovelies
[Music]
gracious sponsor
steps.com
Give It Up
we love stamps please support our
sponsors because they support
the show I love stamps.com man these
guys
crush it
they have taken a service that is
ubiquitous that is present in all of our
lives and they have made it undebatably
better in every way
it's 20 23 baby yep
yep let's step up that small business or
your personal affairs and set your year
up for Success let's get ahead of the
competition by using stamps.com to mail
and ship stamps.com lets you print your
own Postage and shipping labels right
from your home or office it's ready to
go in minutes
and uh then you can get back to doing
things more important things that you
like doing better which is basically
think about it really everything
it's the post office but elevated
okay postage rates keep going up but
luckily stamps.com
has the best prices the biggest
discounts in the entire industry because
they have so much business they work
with over a million businesses they can
negotiate super low rates
that benefits their customers for
example you get 84 percent off USPS and
UPS
yes up to 84 off
that's insane it's huge plus with
stamps.com they'll automatically tell
you what is the cheapest and fastest
shipping options of all of them
available
yeah they've been open for 25 years man
uh and you know they make it seamless if
you're selling online stamps.com it
connects with every major Marketplace
and shopping cart
it's stress free
here's how it works you have a digital
scale that they send you
you mail the postage on the scale
you print it up you put it on the
package here's where it gets great
they'll come to your house and pick it
up wow or you just put in a Dropbox but
you don't even have to go to the email
by the post office
and why would you want to man
you know it's easy it's easy so easy
dude so easy I love stamps.com they're
one of the best man in the game set up
your business for Success when you get
started with stamps.com today sign up
with promo code H3 for special offer
that includes four week trial plus free
postage and a free digital scale there's
no long-term commitment or contracts
go to stamps.com click on the microphone
at the top of the page and enter the
code H3 thank you stamps.com we love
stamps.com yes
yes
[Music]
that's right oh that's when you we love
stamps
um
[Music]
well done
thank you brought you for clean average
you're gonna try positive reinforcement
from now on okay ad reads so what
instead of me admonishing you and
getting mad when you go off the rails in
the ad rain yeah we're gonna try
positive reinforcement you just did a
great adword you stay on the rail
focused on messages okay no
inappropriate jokes okay well done thank
you I don't think it's gonna help but
I'll take the I like that we're
complimenting we tried five years of the
other way so back on the rails
I'm hungry
and I got Subway
do you like subway I'm okay with Subway
I I overdid it in the early days of
being a vegetarian
um when I was quite poor and ate a lot
of fast food that was Subway has like
vegan sandwiches and stuff
um so I ate it a lot you like the veggie
patty they do there yeah very good it's
pretty good yeah yeah
so I've always been you know it's not
amazing but it's solid Subway's fine I
mean for the price
the thing is you know what's always kind
of freaks me out about Subway you get
this massive sandwich it's a foot long
it looks enormous you eat the whole
[__] thing and then
at least for me it's like I don't feel
full
is that the Wellbutrin or the Alexa Pro
like talking because that's a lot of fun
food I get tired I get so full really
for me it's like I crush a whole one of
those things and it's like doesn't even
phase me dude I I I'd agree with that
um thank you there's definitely places
that have bigger sandwiches that are
more satisfying
like Jersey mics they schlap and they're
way bigger
I agree I don't get full from it either
I feel like I don't know what it is it's
the bread is like
it's not real food it's like nothing
it's like deflated and I think they just
they slam it full of veggies and [__] so
it looks bigger I like the veggies but
come on
come on but yeah bang for your buck like
the amount of food
of all the fast food places that's got
to be the best right bang for the buck
now what do you mean bang for the bug
you're talking about like calories per
dollar exactly just purely well maybe
not calories but let's say more broadly
nutrition because at least you get some
veggies and stuff yeah it it is
it's probably less calories than a Big
Mac I mean you can get like fresh
veggies in your sandwich which is kind
of more than anyone else can say right
happy birthday to Violet you're turning
violet violet
she said Ethan please do not wish me a
happy birthday wow he has the sound
you're turning violent violet oh she
wants a shout out from the girls okay
sorry from the girly oh my God
[Applause]
also happy birthday Jill
peace and love turns 21 tomorrow uh Zach
I'm 21. [__] you yeah mm-hmm
there it is
thank you Jamie homo that was very kind
of you thank you all right let's see
we've got so much so should we get
Subway though
would that be a desecration of God have
you had Jimmy John's
Jimmy John Jimmy Crack Corn uh no I've
I've had it sound basically Jimmy John's
is do we know if Jimmy John is a
predator what do we know about Jimmy
John what do we know about Jimmy
chocolate mocha is James Jonathan yeah
they're all different flavors I'm
skeptical of Sandwich men
that's good it was good to be skeptical
who is tell get me some details about
Jimmy John yeah before I spot a sandwich
who is
who is Jimmy John here he is Jimmy John
leotard oh my God he's gonna
he's got a look let me see what this guy
looks like
okay Jimmy I see you there
this is the Papa John's sandwiches this
is what I'm getting right I got the same
feeling I wonder if it's busting hard
I'm telling you so what's the deal Jimmy
are you racist are you a predator I
gotta know there's something up with
this guy he's born in Arlington Heights
Illinois so he's a Midwestern boy okay
is he Midwestern Papa John maybe oh [__]
there's people debating online if
there's a naked picture of him with a
shark it it looks just like him wait
with a shark wait he was caught in bed
with a shark he's not in bed he's in
here I'll send it to you send it to me
privately he's [__] a shark
seems dangerous he's on a boat but all
right let me see this photo put it in
members also
also with the sandwich in his hand and
this
is
[__] a shark dude
wait is he also running does he hunt
rhinos is that what that other photos
people say I'm not down with that's
almost worse than diddling kids almost
let me just be clear people will say
this it's quite bad
oh yeah he looks so sassy oh yeah I am
seeing a bunch of actual photos with him
in rhinos but I guess the one I don't
like him him and the shark isn't really
yeah we don't like him if he's hunting
rhinos I'm not cool with that give me
John is over party
you [__] the Rhinos too
let me look
I mean let me look in here I did find a
picture where it looks like he's [__]
a bear well show me a picture of Jimmy
John with rhinos because so I can show
the people well it's in it they're it's
in the corner of this one I'm not right
you can't try this I'm not pulling this
one up Dan j-rh it's a butt naked man
hugging a dead shark
oh
right I got it
just the right height no bucket is
required
that's a meme we're gonna have to unpack
someday fact check Jimmy John's founder
did hunt big game but is no longer
sandwich shop owner
okay well Origins matter dude what the
[__] bro [__] this Jimmy John [__]
how dare you dude how about Firehouse
how dare respect the firefighters this
man killed an elephant and you're gonna
sit there and put your thumbs up you
monster you're a [__] loser shame on
you loser this is so gross man [__] your
sandwiches bro
what an [__] what a [__] [__]
somebody said post it on Twitter can I
post the the shark [__] on Twitter
sure I don't mind I don't know that it's
well if it's not him we should be clear
about that
I'll just post it without comments some
people speculate that it's him I don't
know if it is or not but it does look
like it does look like him and also
knowing that he's a big game hunter does
add yeah I mean some sense yeah I'm
tweeting it with without calling there's
no by the way there's no like dick or
even yeah it's not that explicit you
just see his little bare bottom yo he's
a piece of [__] no he's hunted a lot
like he has pictures with a leopard a
dead leopard I knew it I knew not to
trust this guy [__] right dude Jimmy
John [__] you dude
[__] you bro
I hate big game Hunters almost more than
anyone it's like you really gonna sit
there
on these beautiful creatures that are
disappearing from this world from a
helicopter minding their own [__] yeah
did what did you do a minigun from a
helicopter and you're gonna sit there
like you did something
this [__] elephant probably had a
family ovens are so smart you know
they're basically non-human
intelligent uh intelligence
[__] you dude
I'm not eating your sandwiches ever
again Jimmy John that's the game they
have the largest brain of any land
animal and three times as many neurons
as humans they have like sophisticated
like communication and [__] like
elephants are straight up
non-human intelligent life look at this
[__] demon
all right pot belly it is
so gross
you guys had Potbelly what an [__]
dude all right what other place we got
that's another sandwich place yeah Sam
you ever had Potbelly
no I have not maybe that's just the
Midwest thing we made Potbelly we got to
do research on all these [__]
sandwich man I'm telling you there's
something with them somebody said uh the
Jersey Mike's owner is always doing ads
for local food drives all right tell me
the best sub in the game tell me about
Jersey Mike also has the stair of a
serial killer that's uh Ryan pull it up
from the chat's contribution so he's
from New Jersey which already is a rough
ride yeah we don't have to a rough start
there it's Mia's 21st birthday Zach uh
founder [__] you
Jersey Mike
his name isn't Mike
okay
white cream yeah they're all different
flavors uh Ohio uh if you want to send
us stickers you can just send it to um
just just message someone on Discord but
thank you for that offer thank you
all right send me a picture of this
scumbag I'm just trying to confirm this
is the right guy
Peter yeah his name Peter can can Crow
but I'm just making sure this is the guy
that founded it so who the [__] is Mike
who is Jersey
probably killed him and assumed his
identity because he's a sandwich guy oh
interesting who is Jersey Mike it says
it started back in
1956.
opened by
by Peter can't can't Crow oh what the
dude his whole [__] life is a lie who
the [__] is Mike
but then they say Mike also benefited
from geographical location of his stores
who's Mike why does it lie who's Mike
oh why is
not a place that was originally called
Mike's
Subs
that's so weak Mike's all week no but no
they're saying there's a guy named Mike
Mike opened the small shop
on the seaside town of New Jersey
you have to remember that in 1956 there
are very few franchise restaurants in
hamburgers no chain Pizza I don't care
they talking about Mike dude yeah but
you see it you see it too Jersey Mike
found her like Wikipedia founder Peter
okay okay the guy who made it was Mike
the dude who made it popular was Peter
that such Stolen Valor dude you're not a
[__] Mike Peter started working at
Mike's Subs at age 14. he loved Mikes
he loved authentic submarines he's the
guy this is the guy we need to look into
yeah he's riding like puff pieces about
himself but even more Peter loved
working behind the counter interacting
and talking with customers this guy's
this guy's a [__] demon nobody nobody
likes him he's lying he's a total liar
Frog who are you Peter
who is he
before I buy your sandwich
okay how Mike Jersey Mike CEO turned 125
000 into a billion dollar company
yeah that's just that's just Peter again
I'm sick of Peter Peter's the guy who
the Peter's the guy he's the one who
made it Peter worked for Mike but
they're like Mike's dead he's gone
that's I think that that's upsetting I
feel like we've we've like lost a piece
of History here because everybody's just
talking about Peter as if Mike didn't
exist
I feel like I'm going crazy the place is
called Mike's who's Mike okay here I got
some dirt
The Untold Truth of Jersey Mike's there
we go
thank God someone's telling the story
take Jersey Mike's for example it's not
exactly a mom and pop independent corner
store but compared to some of the bigger
names it might as well be a hot dog cart
shut up
edge of bankruptcy making money getting
his hands dirty
all right did you get paid for this [__]
like what the [__] dude
keeping it fresh dude what the hell what
what is this Untold [__] this is
propaganda
absolute propaganda of giving wow
there's a cover up here shame on you
mash there's a cover-up going on here
I'm gonna I want to pay mash.com to
write article about Ethan's actually the
greatest guy he's never done anything
controversial
he's super generous and makes super
funny content [__] you I'm not I'm not
eating Jersey Mike Zach I don't trust
him
I'm sorry like that he's up to something
letting the dog go anything else
uh any other sandwich places we can Riff
on okay here we go here's a post from
Reddit with two upvotes Jersey Mike's is
even worse than Chick-fil-A when it
comes to human rights
Chick-fil-A's Loki anti-lgbt Q for sure
but it's solely because their vision of
Evangelical is a cult while they're blah
blah blah so Dan Cathy is no longer
Jersey Mike's founder is really
anti-semitic oh [__] he puts blame on
all black folks for their crimes
committed in poor areas and rural areas
and he said BLM is a terrorist
organization if you can find that quote
I'm out apparently he said though
funded to be the he funded the proud
boys and Boogaloo boys okay hold on how
do you know all this because I didn't
I think this was written by um
uh Peter can Crow funded the proud boys
but buddy did this post with two votes
dude we just stumbled upon something
well it's one thing to be anti-blm it's
another thing that goes as far as
founder of the restaurant being allowed
and proud of being a racist idiot
okay okay when I search
Peter cancrow Proud boys the
top result is that two-up vote Reddit
thread so I think it might not be a
whole lot to go on here wait what was
the last sandwich place we were invest
investigating uh Jimmy John's I think
Jimmy John wrote that oh interesting
sabotage yeah corporate sabotage for
sure
all right well if you guys want to order
sandwiches we gotta find someone with
Clean Hands telling you Firehouse okay
the firefighters
well we better look into it Firehouse
Subs Firehouse Subs who are you founder
founded by Jared Fogle what no by Robin
Sorenson and Chris Sorensen okay we got
two
two siblings I imagine right the
Sorenson sibs here they are let's take a
look it's called Firehouse because they
used to burn down orphan orphanages
skinny
[Applause]
uh
uh the brothers uh follow the same
career path as their father Rob Sorensen
who what also founded us so we need to
go back
a 43-year veteran of the fire and uh
rescue Department in Jacksonville
Florida
oh they're from Jacksonville Florida
this is already that's rough uh oh hey
it's like the guy in the left side I
like the spicy meatball the guy on the
right's like I ate the vegetarian we're
brothers
oh Burger King bought them out for 1
billion
bro I can't support that it's just a
Burger King shell Company
Burger King owns The Firehouse Subs
according to these two articles I just
went through yeah huh a butter Burger
King parent I said Burger super Arab
right there's a Burger King parent uh
completes one billion acquisition of
Firehouse Subs million dollars so insane
if I want Burger King I'll buy Burger
King well it's not just restaurant
Brands International it's one of these
like conglomerates that owns a bajillion
I'm not doing I'm not supporting this
Pepsi dude Popeyes too yeah
Burger King you know well if you want to
talk about Pepsi then I'm pretty sure
they're like
they're like using if it's Pepsi they're
probably you know
date it's probably like carbonated
[__] blood of mass Graves of children
dug in Indonesia that's how they
carbonate it that's right thank you
oh apparently they don't do not own
Burger King Cassidy Shannon thank you
for the five gifted Robin Chris
[Music]
butter good
all right so if you guys I'm telling you
I need clean hands on myself I'm I'm
digging so far no dirt on the sorensons
they just they're they're they were
firefighters and now they own a sub
place that they sold for a billion
dollars I eat I like the spicy I like
the chicken parmesan with extra cheese I
eat the vegan patio together
we're the sub we're the sandwich
Brothers
I've looked Robin Chris Sorensen
accusations
um
Scandal they seemed clean all I found is
that one of the place uh one of these
shops in Alabama the owner threatened a
customer and said he would kill them
well that's camping you can't blame for
that yeah I know
what about fat cell
Fat Sal what's fat cells interesting
that place sucks shut up it is so good I
like that yeah it's not good why would
you say that bro it's not good it's just
too greasy there's too much going on
it's not a it's not a sub why are you
saying that when I first moved here Zach
told me it wasn't good because there was
one by the old office and so when I
would go there sometimes I picked one up
and it was amazing
and what has Sal done to anyone except
make them a delicious sandwich you guys
should see the the menus on fat cell
because I think this is just an LA thing
look at this menu you guys yeah is it
yeah it's just an LA thing
just L.A there's too much going on it is
a lot
wrong
all right here's here's signature
sandwiches hold on uh let's see
pep oh God
Sal's Burgers what the [__] why it's not
a sandwich place these are actually
totally normal bro it's variety joint
Heroes he's got signature Heroes man
yeah ham salami pepperoni provolone
sweeter hot pepper shred so this is like
a normal sandwich Bruh Bruh
what about Blimpies you guys got
Blimpies out here I've heard of that one
um maybe there sounds too much like
blippi
wimpy yeah
they're from Arizona
um
I just see blippi anyone here from
Arizona everyone uh
uh the firehouse uh guys are clean we're
giving them this firehouses clean so if
that's what you want to do the problem
is they're not local no they're not a
local business it's Burger King bro
you want to support Burger King
so it was Subway
yeah we said no Subway
we're not excluding big change we passed
on subway no no I'm just saying the
chain I don't think there's any in the
area
oh maybe not I mean there's ones in La I
know that before I even got to the
multi-national chain conversation I got
stuck up at the Jared Fogle pedophile
right it was the pedophile I didn't get
to go down Subway right it's like a flow
chart
all right as the search continues I will
uh move on
but I'm thinking fat Sal's you know what
I'm saying
oh someone said Firehouse Subs has
donated 73 million they're good guys I
had a feeling we love the firefighters
is there a Firehouse Sub place nearby oh
there is yes I know there's one are they
where one is but it's too far to deliver
here but
so but Sam's saying there is one there's
one uh yeah there's a dentist enough
yeah let me take a look at this menu
because I don't know that I've ever even
eaten here
okay
and you guys don't [__] up because I'm
if I'm eating one of these sandwiches
this is going to retroactively affect me
AB have you ever had a pub sub I know
you've uh been to Florida you've lived
in Florida right it sounds so familiar
Publix oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah Pub
sub I didn't know that's what they were
called but yes I have yeah that's what
they call them that's so funny yep okay
get me in Italian
where's the biggest [__] size they
have
[Music]
kavish our Italian sub is loaded with
Geneva salami pepperoni ham
provolone lettuce tomato onion Mayo Deli
okay
not crazy about the ham but whatever it
is that's taken
listen
[Music]
you're breaking my heart
listen
I'm talking to the big fat one
I'm getting a sandwich that I think you
should understand
you know this is okay I'm not even good
I don't know let's focus yeah okay I
just want the I just want the Italian
and so I can move on with the show
you guys just
boom
yeah thank you
okay that was a lot
come on Sub sub talk
not sub talk
um moving on we've got
a new AI edit oh great
this ai's out of control you guys are
supposed to be rich Jordan Peterson is
right all these haters talking about the
doxing situation oh God as you know we
had another doxying situation where I
revealed to the world uh the precise
location of Olivia's apartment
coordinates all of it yeah and so
predictably all of my detractors have
made videos calling me out for doxing
one of my employees here it is rich
okay Olivia you live in an apartment on
Wilshire you have an apartment
[Music]
you've done
Ethan Klein just doxed his employee
Olivia is this your hero liberals and we
now know that Olivia guardian of all
that is slay lives in the greater West
Los Angeles area I love Olivia and I
used to love Ethan he needs to take some
cues from boss Queen Ela telling your
fans that Olivia lives in the 80 square
mile region west of downtown L.A
not East L.A not San Gabriel Valley no
not sfv not even Glendale we must
protect Olivia and relocate her to Tech
thanks you guys
good afternoon thank you for coming
I'll try to make this brief
what do you think Klein has done here
today is unforgivable and requires
immediate intervention
he cannot be allowed to go Goblin mode
any longer it is time I took matters
into my own hands thank you this is
crazy I literally have to defend myself
this video is awesome
[__] love these people
yeah apologies Olivia I am sorry about
that that is totally fine I don't think
anyone's gonna you know
come on Ethan where are you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
I got your back buddy
what is this seat
uh that was so funny
just throw Jay Leno crashing in there
incredible yeah I think it worked yeah
oh my god dude that's awesome
[Music]
it did in fact not work probably that
was the uh same person I made the uh
Roxy edit Obsession on the subs oh cbk
101 thank you thank you with peace and
love
foreign
you dead wait why
did did you really say it President Dan
you're going rogue
[__]
dad but people are threatening to say
something crazy but people didn't even
don't even get to see me doing that yeah
you did they think they'll think that
you did I was doing a joke about oh
could I say something crazy but they
don't even see that
I waited a little bit for so I didn't
cut out the video I don't know I'll have
to go look back but damn I also just
wanted to show off our new uh our new
hold screens uh because um we did a
bunch of people submitted uh funny
technical difficulties cards to the
subreddit and so we've Incorporated them
into our uh into our cutaway Loop uh cam
made a few as well that are pretty great
so Dan went rogue you guys this was
unauthorized button used and I guess
[__]
who where are we if Dan goes robe a lot
of people say why does Ethan have the
button it's worth mentioning Dan also
has a button I have the button I have
the button it's a double launch codes my
button is virtual it's just a window on
my screen I don't have a physical button
which is a lot less fun but is it a big
ass button on your screen it says it's
customizable I can make it the entire
screen if you want to we need a whole
screen for the button
all right Dan
so anyway thank you to them I don't even
know if you guys saw it now
hey did you guys know about this I was
just browsing again tick tock
and I'm I be I've gone viral you guys on
Tick Tock for something other than Jim
being a gym beta
so that's pretty fun uh this sound
here okay Tick Tock are you for real
right now again
weird lack
of respect for the sanctity of life
again maybe I'm overacting but I feel
like
this was me talking about Logan Paul's
all this weird animals dying I think
it says seven-year-old me when my
classmate would torture and kill
inchworms during recess
but then if you go to the sound
there's a whole it's go we're going
viral guys we're going viral
again
weird black
of respect for the sanctity of life
again this is it these these ladies are
popping off I think Lena had a viral one
you know I was gonna say didn't you use
this a little while ago wait you used
this one I did scroll down oh here you
are okay Queen wait how long ago again
has this been one week ago okay yeah
here's Lena popping off when I'm sitting
outside with my Arab dad any comments on
what all the neighbors are doing
weird lack
of respect for the sanctity of life
again
yes popping off some of these are really
big so I feel like accomplished and it's
100 or well
I think it's 100 ladies okay there's one
dude who's doing it
the dudes are like no bro if I use this
sound by it makes me
makes me gay or something Lena put out
one last week that had like nine million
views and Barstool reached out to her to
share it
it was me being cringe wait did you did
you grant it uh to them
she did not know it not knowing they
were enemies oh it's not no it's not I
told them they can use it they're a huge
media because actually I did get a few
messages of companies wanting to license
it and then when I click on the link
like they want the rights to my video
and I'm like no but Barstool they just
want to like post it and I said yeah
that's fine you got to get viral hog to
pay for this [__] or something wait what
is this milk chocolate hazelnut milk
that's what it is
I gotta hear
milk chocolate hazelnut is it milk
chocolate Asian nut oh that's okay
that's what a lot of people think he's
saying milk chocolate hazelnut okay milk
chocolate hazelnut that's what it is oh
you said I'll take the milk chocolate I
thought he was offering one or the other
yeah which is a fair why did he get so
angry
a lot of people think he was getting
like he was mean about it but he wasn't
he was just being playful because he was
doing that with other customers it was
schtick I hope so I don't know I hope
well it worked so why did you record
this I feel like you guys news you guys
are little schemers with this [__] no
I've been doing like um daily Vlogs on
my tick tocks oh so I've just been like
kind of recording everything and then at
the end of the day like I'll pick and
choose what to include that's so funny
Lena your hair looks beautiful today oh
yeah you want curly thank you so much
yeah I love it well this is my natural
hair I just blow dry it today I figured
I'll I'll style what I have again
um I've never seen you with your hair
like that yeah I've never I've never
worn my natural curls like this and so
when you shower does your hair go just
like totally curly yes and really it
gets really big and Frizzy so that's why
I was always afraid to just leave it
natural wow so every morning you are
spending a significant amount of time
doing your hair no because I only wash
my hair like once a week maybe um
but yeah I never keep it natural I'll
always have to blow dry it or something
out of the shower this is a woman thing
that I just don't really understand as a
guy
a lot of women they wash their hair once
a week and to me as a greasy old [__]
meatball that is to me
feels and sounds gross
I'm not saying you're gross because I
know a lot of women do it but I was
genuinely shocked when I found out about
this and I tell you I
dated a girl in college
who did not wash your hair for the same
reason and this turn this killed me she
put baby powder you do that but yeah
that's like a hack for when you're gonna
smell like baby powder yeah she put a
bunch of baby powder on her scalp she
sounds smart she sounds Nifty incredible
but it was but when I was with her I
just smelled baby powder it was so
gnarly well now I I actually don't know
when the surgeons of dry shampoos was
but they have really good smelling dry
shampoos there's some in the bathroom
what's a dry shampoo
you could wear it throughout the day
right dry shampoo yeah wait what is a
dry shampoo do this magical it just yeah
here go ahead Olivia oh it's like a
spray and it absorbs the oil from your
scalp and then you just like tap out if
there's residue
does it make this smell of baby powder
go away oh dude I'm pissing everyone off
now that you've got the ladies guys I'm
just saying as a dude we just we live
different kinds of lives now I I have to
wash my hair because I get [__]
disgusting but I know that you all are
beautiful tulips that never get oily or
stinky or anything like me right never
guys back me up I mean what the hell no
I always wash my hair every day when I
was younger then I found out that it was
doing damage so it's only more recently
that I only do it like a couple times a
week three times maybe and it doesn't
dry out your hair the only damage bro
you put like even like you you bleach
your hair with like that's what I'm
saying hair's falling out of your head
that's why I need to pay attention to it
yeah sorry go ahead Lina
just because you wash your hair every
day do you ever feel like it kind of
dries out no oh that's how it is for me
at least okay you can do it every day
you have like superhuman hair though no
my hair is the opposite I get really
oily and nasty if I don't wash it
regularly dude I swear there's these
magical products that are just for women
usually then I've kind of like learned
about over the years like dry shampoo I
tried it a couple times with like
friends and it's like magic dude you
don't have to shower
really you really feel like your hair is
clean yeah it really like dries your
hair like on oils your hair can you do
that can I put that on my face
has anyone try that let's see grease
what is this [__] it's like some some
like bile grade uh chemical that cleans
up oil spills they're like oh let's put
it in our hair
there it is women be shopping
I'm sure there's more product you guys
have to share them with us oh 100 I'll
think of I'll think about all the other
magic gadgets that I have all right
sounds great
so there it is we are watching well
what's the longest you'll go without
washing your hair Olivia a week a week
I'll go and how often do you apply okay
we have some dry shampoo here thank you
Sam and and do you apply baby powder to
your scalp I apply a dry shampoo dry
shampoo is okay this is unscented dry
shampoo
I'm talking baby powder yeah I have used
baby it's it's essentially the same
concept because it's a powder that
absorbs oil but doesn't it stink don't
you hate the smell of baby powder I
don't
but you do I really do yeah well if I'm
like
okay guys sorry if I'm being if I'm like
being intimate and we're like in bed and
being intimate whatever I just I don't
want to smell
baby powder that's my preference that's
how I felt
but again I'm just one man
I used to put olive oil in my hair is
like a man a mask olive oil I
you were putting olive oil in as a mask
yeah what's a mess I wouldn't like keep
it I would just put it in my hair for a
little bit before I shower oh so you
wash it out
yeah yeah why did you hate it baby
[__] reminded me of being poor I
hated it just the smell of the olive oil
reminded me of like all we used to eat
when I was younger was just like eggs
and olive oil I [__] hated it olive
oil is very expensive ingredient not
well we had potatoes and olive oil I
guess not in uh Lebanon or well wherever
you I used to do that
it's great well we we brought the
recipes over
all right so I've got dry shampoo
whatever the [__] this is not your
mother's it says
that's the brand
clean freak refresh well it's not I know
you're not a clean freak
I'm just gonna give you you tend to get
like um rash on your face when you try
stuff just you might just [__] your face
off with that so we've got as long as
we've got Benadryl I'm good all right it
says instantly absorb this is so funny
it's like dummy [__]
I'm almost like the singleest man alive
and also like the most married man alive
at the same time
the singleest man alive discovers women
products
[Music]
unscented fragrance free instant absorbs
oil fresh without water no visible
residue
lay now wash later okay Shake vigorously
doing that motion on the green screen is
a mistake
oh God Ethan oh my God you you just
[__] up
you just [__] up [__] them do it do
whatever you want to me bro
I love it
says hold 8 to 10 inches away and spray
onto the roots massage thoroughly with
fingertips and brush through
[Music]
all right I'm gonna do it this is
flammable
highly flammable in fact
you guys ever used to do that when
you're a kid was like light a fire and
then spray hell yeah yeah [__]
everything on fire
I just make sure it's shaken vigorously
enough
it's shook
whoa whoa
whoa oh my God it's too much shaking it
says vigorously I just want to make sure
I'm hitting the right notes Here
all right well my I did when did I
shower left
I think last night
[Music]
it might be early but I feel like it's
already greasy that's the thing
I have a ball then are you kidding okay
so
eight to ten inches
this
okay
[Music]
more a lot that's no that's it I mean
you didn't really get any towards the
front
it's one more Spritz yeah just one more
Spritz from the front
is this due on scalp but I would need to
do like this to get my scalp that's your
scalp it says do eight to ten inches
though
where you're supposed to kind of like
part your hair a little bit and then do
it on the sky my hair is way too thick
for all that goodness there's no part
I'm trying to find the stuff yeah I'll
just do like this
because that's it that's the only way
it's gonna work
right now
all right now I'm gonna massage it into
my scalp like that yeah massage it in
rub it in
okay I feel like the dryness
not yet then I don't know I feel yeah I
feel a little chalky or something yeah
there you go yeah
someone in chat said it's greasy because
you're washing it too much
I don't know if that's it no trust me I
I've gone three days without
showering or without washing my hair
it's it's not that it just gets greasier
and greasier trust me I think it's a
more usually like a long term like if if
you shower every day for like a year
your body is kind of like reproduce that
and if you just stop for three days of
that year it's Gonna Keep producing it
but if you like wait or if you try to
make a flower for a long time go months
yeah you get used you guys you got to
trust me on this my hair is not like
yours get to liver King status there's
no smell they're right no scent okay
that's nice really no scent
now does it feel less greasy
to be honest it feels exactly the same
sometimes you have to give it a second
and it like absorbs the grease on your
head sometimes I'll put it in before I
go to bed so that when I wake up
and it I guess maybe my hair is not
greasy enough because I did shower last
night I find it makes my hair very dry
um when I use dry shampoo I think that's
the point right which I can't stand
it's bad
um
but uh that's why I use a native uh
shampoo and conditioner that's right
native shampoo and
[Applause]
conditions.com use code H3 you guys rust
me y'all don't know what my hair is like
you have no idea people are going oh I'm
sorry Ethan but love is right you guys
don't know what it's like to be me
okay I've gone periods where I don't
shower as much
just being honest um
they I get greasier you don't know what
it's like to be me you can't see my
scalp I can't even use these products
it's a spray on your scalp where how
you guys don't know my life everyone's
oh your hair's so nice I wish I had like
that no you don't you don't understand
what you're talking about
you think you want my hair but you don't
okay
it's like a monkey paw wish oh I wish I
had Ethan's hair monkey finger down
guess what you wake up and help
trust me
stop it
[Music]
it's 8 P.M
you open your eyes open
your hair you look at me this is me
y'all that's what my hair is like
it's 8 P.M you wake up in a sweat
you go to your hair you applied the dry
shampoo
when you fell asleep
but you go to your hair it's greasy this
is weird I've never it experienced this
I went to the bathroom
shock in the mirror staring back at you
is someone you've never seen before it's
familiar but different
to your hair straight
light brown
but in the mirror is the dense
overgrown
unruly forced of thick brown matted hair
[Music]
you feel oily
in a panic you run to the shower you
realize that the dry shampoo hasn't
taken hold
you shampoo twice while in the shower to
get the grease out you think you're
clean
Head and Shoulders twice
some collected the dry hair made into a
painter's brush gifted it to their
grandmother
you crash cut you wake up you are Jordan
Peterson your grandmother's pubes are
are brushing on your face oh no not
again then dressing up in lingerie
before your mirror at home tucking your
dick between your legs imagining you
have a vagina for sexual kick although
there's nothing sexual about that you
try to push her away Grandma has
absolute Liars you try to have you try
to push her away but grandma has her way
I dreamed I saw my maternal grandmother
sitting by the bank the swimming pool no
no no no a river
Virginia no no no no no no no no dimly
had the appearance of a thick mad of
hair no no no no no no no
this is a nightmare wake me up
wake up yeah
pubic hair more dry shampoo please
[Music]
on the line
of mine this isn't happening
I wish I had my old hair hair
I wish I had my old hair hair hair hair
hair
okay all right enough
thank you explain that to a new viewer
and that's that bucko thank you for the
five gifted Donuts love me some donuts
eh you guys can suck a fat donut okay
okay so moving on I don't know what the
[__] where we gotta hit yeah
we love a natural uh Queen
yes
she there
yeah we were talking about you thank you
thank
you thank you you're very welcome you're
very welcome yeah you're welcome
it's my honor but yeah basically just to
uh shout out the lovely ladies of tick
tock who are my only
friends and fans these are the only
people who are not embarrassed to post
weird lack
of respect for the sanctity when you go
out for dinner in the summer with people
who don't believe in getting apps
special bevies and post-dinner ice cream
tea of life I am right there with you
girl if we don't have po if we don't
have special bevies what do we have
coital regrets about that Today's Show
breakdown we got a breakdown
um this is interesting we've been going
for what looks to be about an hour and a
half
hour 40. hour 40 we've spent 17 minutes
talking about the Oscars that was very
topical that's in the title so that
makes sense we've spent 40 minutes
talking about food
well okay was it really okay four
sandwiches yeah it was probably about 40
minutes and hair we've talked about for
25 minutes so okay uh we have to get a
little bit on topic here
let's see you know speaking of dry hair
some people like their hair moist for
instance moist critical hey wow
are you saying that he likes his hair
moist sure because it's his name and he
has long hair and it seemed like a nice
little tie-in red hair okay yeah let's
move out we have so many good stuff at
the top man it's hard to move on I
haven't even gotten out of the top let
me see if there's anything really
particular here I want to talk about
um this is pretty funny I'll just do
this real fast keemstar got kicked out
of a Twitter space
he's down so bad he's like he's like
[__] is he doing anything now AB does
he like have any presence on the
internet he's got something I don't know
if it's not opposed to the subreddit I
have no idea right 16 is the age of
consent
so here he is apparently in a boxing
chat and uh here he gets obviously
getting a lot of respect from his peers
I'm literally bitching at somebody
interrupting me and then
it's not that
thing
go to the gym
get the [__] out of it [__] ass [__]
that's right I don't come in these chats
but think probably about influencer
boxing but what's funny is he's in there
arguing getting booted out of 135 people
chat rooms
yeah
that's awesome also
interesting keemstar update as you know
we canceled our bow blacks dolls
keemstar and an effort to stick it to us
committed to buying how many did he buy
like 100 or something it was whatever
amount you had originally bought I don't
think he ponied up for the whole thing
because we were gonna buy like 200 of
them
well anyway he bought a ton of bowlex
dolls to prove that he's the good guy I
am not and he's right
he nailed it and now he's got a box full
of 200 Bobby's boxes that he that his
broke ass spent what like eight thousand
dollars on to stick it to me and now
he's trying to pawn them off selling
Bobby dolls for a hundred dollars each
man Brantley gonna be walking around
like a Girl Scout selling those
hello ma'am would you like would you
guys be interested in buying a Bobby
plushie today oh [__] they got on my
part and so actually I think we took the
biggest dub of all time it's pretty good
we literally got keemstar to waste
thousands of dollars on what can only be
described as the dumbest plushie ever
made
hundreds of them hundreds of them people
saying we never told them about the
cancellation yeah we did
yeah we mentioned it yeah guys
to uh clown on myself
he he was doing he was saying some
whatever I don't want to get back into
it because
Beau black still won against the family
he went against the he went against the
Golden State yeah
but that's so so congratulations
keemstar the incredible and lucky owner
of 200 BubbleBox dolls acoustic version
of some [__] it doesn't make sense I
foresee keemstar trying to shake down
Beau blocks for his money back I see
that happening
feels that he's like an Avon lady he's
got a garage full of Boby dolls he
doesn't know what to do with hundred
dollars each come on guys one of a kind
that's so good all right so anyway
moving on that was just a fun little
thing but let's talk about the main
stories now let's talk about
I don't know how much I've talked about
um can we talk about what's going on
with the environment can we talk about
other things that's not in the document
um Jada
um Jaden whatever who cares
I see Jordan Peterson elk boys where's
the
where's the crit [__] the crit [__] uh I
just saw it on top of the show I think
yeah it's highlighted top of the show
why is it that you're making these lines
black who did that
I'm doing that I'm trying to make it
easier for you to find I'm just black
I'm blacking out stuff we've already
talked about I don't know that's fine I
don't need that okay thank you black I
appreciate the initiative but kind of
weird looking
I mean I like when you highlight it like
that black is you know I mean you can
highlight it like that I like that
um
okay can you high like I have a
highlighter with that
16. why doesn't
hold on number 16 in the top of the show
yeah okay let's do this
moist critical I don't know how much
we've talked about sneako
he's in this whole uh realm of you know
we've talked about them on the show
before
um he's like the shittiest here he's
almost more [__] tier than fresh and fit
he's like the bottom of the barrel yeah
I mean we had never even heard of him
until he kind of inserted himself into
all of the Andrew Tate Discord
um discourse rather and
he he was uh he was a fallen fan
remember we we discovered that yeah
right right
so uh
but that's about the extent of uh our
interaction with him
so his descent into uh incel dumb is
actually quite interesting because he
used to make
um
oh God Chad is so [__] annoying
sometimes I don't even know I'm looking
at it right
[Music]
once you have that ready to go so fast
it's just how I operate Jesus
um so
sneako his descent into incel dumb was
actually quite interesting because he
used to make
kind of interesting cerebral like almost
lib content I mean he used to be a fan
of ours
and then something happened to him
he used to attend sex parties with his
girlfriend they were into that kind of
thing
which is great if that's what you're
into
but he went to a sex party with his
girlfriend and he witnessed her getting
like railed and [__] on and bukakidon
and stuff and it I think it broke him
because ever since that
he's gone like full red pill
from being actually cooked which is
interesting because that's what they
call
he he had made this um
collage of people who hurt his feelings
on the internet yeah like a school
shooter
bro what the [__] you're so pathetic bro
you made a school shooter the tier list
here these are the people that made fun
of me
these are the people that hurt my
feelings I will never forgive you I will
never forget
[Music]
I keep the pictures of you guys on my
wall because you hurt my feelings
if I ever see you
I will accept me I will talk I will have
words to exchange with you buddy
nobody's mean to me on the internet
schnico of course who got permanently
banned on YouTube for mock
essaying somebody
he was make fun of an essay Survivor by
reenacting he's just I mean he's
disgusting he he was saying that a
female Creator needed to to get some
action and then he yeah simulated
something here is snico representing in
my opinion one of the best merches we've
done I love it so shout out bro shout
out no refunds [__]
[Laughter]
yeah but he used to be cool he used to
be like kind of I don't know but he went
down the wrong path
and um
I don't really love it he blames all
those people in the collage and not you
know any any sort of reflection on the
fact that within what like three months
of getting involved with a bunch of
neo-nazis and Andrew Tate and all those
people he lost everything you think yeah
he doesn't he he doesn't a little
something to do with it maybe like
long career on the internet and then
three months in to uh associating with
these people you're gone I don't know
yeah so he's slowly becoming more
radical
and then when he met Tate I think either
he saw like an opportunity to become
like get on this grift
or he really believes it it's hard to
know sometimes but
yeah he says pattern recognition this
collages everyone who advocated for my
cancellation is he I guess he's implying
and he's tweeted this a lot if you could
find more examples he's implying that
we're all soys or cut he says cucks
which is funny because he actually is a
cup he got cucked
right I've never been below and there's
nothing wrong with it again you know I'm
not one for kingship and I think that's
fantastic if that's what you love and
everybody's having fun but you shouldn't
call someone cut when you've actually
been cucked if you're using it as an
insult of course because what that would
imply is that the trauma is is something
within yourself that you're trying to
address
Hassan who's like jacked by the way I
don't know how he's trying to make him
seem like some soy boy
Hassan is like [__] enormously jacked
also the fattest picture of me ever
that's awesome
but that's true that's my face
you know don't like soy milk
incidentally I do enjoy oat milk
uh that's my preference
just to tell you how are you going to
milk a note that's the question on
everyone's mind
and uh he apparently he's had an ongoing
beef with Charlie critical
I'm not super familiar with their beef
but they went like back and forth and I
like Char I like when Charlie calls out
people like this you know he's got a
really big platform and sneako really is
just a bottom feeding [__] loser so
the less people that like him the better
so Charlie responded to this uh this
post
that has his face on it he says holy
[__] you're pathetic
sensitive soy little worm I made fun of
you for watching a girlfriend get [__]
by numerous other men
and insulted you for defending child p
word oh yeah he said that his one of his
favorite movies is
what is it called
cutie Beauties cuties of course was the
movie on Netflix that was widely
criticized for depicting uh young girls
in like a sexual manner that was very
unsettling and weird
and that he said was his favorite movie
in fact if you guys have time stamps I'd
love to show that as well as the
anecdote of him watching his of him
saying he's a [__]
now I'm not feeling to say he liked it
it's his favorite movie he said really
my favorite movie I'm pretty sure that's
what he said
yeah we'll pull it up but I'm pretty
sure he said it's his favorite movie
perhaps you're on the Jared Fogle
emailing list
do you like Subway sandwiches perhaps
Nico
oh he keeps adding so he has his this is
his photo of grievances
this goes back he he uh crit hadn't yet
made it to the list so
uh oh crit put all this in his video
that's pretty good yeah
because I don't really want to watch the
whole thing but yeah the whole video is
long if you can grab the time stamp so
sneaka says you are who you spend time
with interesting you spent like one day
with Andrew Tate and lost everything
all of us are addicted to social media
be careful who you follow there's no
time left to play video games watch porn
and watch celebrity drama
watch as I create celebrity drama does
your favorite content creator stand for
anything
they look identical because their
beliefs are identical
I mean I don't think they don't look a
song like Ethan and Charlie's beliefs
are identical I think that's also we
don't look anything like you put line up
there's not three more different looking
people I feel like
you know
and then um and he's all the Fate he
keeps going all the faces that make
documentary hit pieces on myself and
educate resist the soy mind he says
yes he's very he's very upset about this
it's clearly
I don't know if I've seen a bigger radio
than that ever like 300 what was it 50
000 likes the original
um
oh sorry oh it's not in this one yet no
I'm not looking at this is just all the
times he's posted this because he's so
angry about these mean Bullies Are
teasing me and making fun of me Andrew
Tate
Andrew what do I do when these these
boys on the internet are being so cruel
they're being so mean to me
I forgive and love all the soy boys who
tried to cancel me thanks bro Gotti
you keep bringing it up it's actually
just like wow
straight Hit List dude the soy boy
collage the YouTubers who have made hit
piece videos on me continues to expand
yet none of them will ever address the
glaringly obvious trend in this picture
what they're not supposed to like me
what what's the what is
what's the trend
there's a trend you're all not
mentioning they all have hair
snako is of course baldless or
hairlessly right so maybe
red hair yeah Charlie
um said you watched your girlfriend get
[__] nah I don't I'm not
insulting him for that
just think if you're gonna call someone
a [__] as an insult
clearly something you hold and disdain
then it's not you might be a hypocrite
if your girlfriend gets boot conquied in
front of you
just bukhakied all in front of you bro
just ah yeah dude you're jerking off in
the corner you can't get it up you're
flaccid and there's just these big bull
Brad the Bull type of dudes who are just
you know
hit that hard
fluids everywhere hers and theirs
and you're just in the corner you're
masturbating with your tears but it
doesn't work here's
you know you'll never please your girl
like those dudes did and that ultimately
is what broke you right because you as a
man
that kind of defined you as a man right
like you think you're the sexual
desirable being but in that moment you
are nothing but a but a worthless child
a discard a Discord a tampon if you
would a discarded [__] rag if you would
and so that hit you hard
you know and I get that it sounds tough
uh he said I also insulted you for
defending child p word that's not
cancellation that's just spitting on you
for being a pitiful sad cuck Charlie
calls him a cuck
again
nothing wrong with being a [__]
he says he responds to him you know in
your soul you would never say that to my
face that I mean that it's like bro shut
the [__] up he doesn't need to say it to
your face
also why would I want to say it to your
face when you have a school shooting
[__] kill list like I'd rather not
say it to your face you're clearly a
homicidal maniac dude don't go to school
tomorrow
don't go to YouTube headquarters
tomorrow says sneako
I mean you're a [__] loot bro you you
this is literally the attic in your head
do you know how pathetic it is that you
keep posting this
you know what I mean
it's so funny Charlie responds you
literally have a collage of people that
hurt your feelings on the internet
you haven't stopped whining about me for
months now you goofy NPC this is the
language he uses I'm assuming Charlie's
trying to make a point right
even if you beat my ass in a fight it
doesn't change the truth you're still a
cuck who also defends child p word
yeah and of course you know you're
what is the physical fight mean to you
exactly you know does you beating me up
or coming to my school and shooting me
during recess on unbukaki your
girlfriend
the semen gonna magically go back into
their penises no
and it doesn't change the fact that you
probably made out with her later that
night
which some people are into but you have
the taste of their semen on your lips
forever
you know
snico says you're not special from the
other 10 soy boys who say the same thing
if you've got a problem stop talking on
the internet let's solve it bro you are
so pathetic loser shut up dumbass
someone in shot pointed out the views to
like radio 10 million views versus
Jesus yo dude you're serious like you're
supposed to be a role model like let's
meet in the McDonald's parking lot at
2am
to Charlie who by the way is variant fit
but he's short guy
so will you you want to fight him how
about you just
seriously bro that's cool
okay
Charlie respondent got your Discord
still working on responses brother I
have no problem you started and I made
fun of you in return you're upset about
publicly admitting to cup holder
cuckoldery
and get mad at me for bringing it up you
should be mad at yourself instead have
some self-reflection right
Fair Point
oh that did snico dip after that
fight me bro
fight me
it's so funny too uh because Charlie has
made mentioned sneako a couple times
maybe three maybe four and sneaker has
been going on and on crying about it and
sending that picture we were talking
about earlier like for months he's so
bothered by it it's actually incredible
yeah you know what this is actually the
second time he's been cooked
I think moist critical just cut them
again [__] all over if he's got a
girlfriend Charlie just [__] all over
now he's got a kiss and offer right Dan
right
I was looking for a tweet so I wasn't
really paying attention I was just
looking for backup
it was getting too quiet what did I just
agree to or you don't you'll have to
watch
uh that was pretty good though yeah I
the sneak goes pretty low on my radar
I've talked about him a few times it's
just sad and pathetic kind of like
uh does I mean he really is a cautionary
tale of like what your brain can become
on the red pill the red pill you know
uh but let's see there's actually
link okay so here's Charlie's video
apparently I have not watched it but it
is very good apparently here's Nico
dancing with a gun the [__]
here let me pull you some highlights
from Charlie who's in a who's in a
karate ghee
what's up now
um
about this the day after I posted my
response he went on stream and had a
huge unhinged tantrum and meltdown about
the whole holy [__] bro you I was just
joking about how he's a school shooter
yeah this man is now dancing around with
a handgun with pictures of people who
said main things about him on the
internet look at you want to be Tate the
interesting you and Tate is that you're
in like a [__] tiny pillbox apartment
you've been a strange and alienated from
everyone you love and you're having a
mental breakdown on the internet for the
whole world to see you are not Andrew
Tate you are like his [__] stained you
are like the shell of a Cuban he sucked
the life force out of you and left
I think Andrew Tate must be some kind of
brain parasite because like he's told he
stole his life force and left him an
empty shell who's who's like in love
with Andrew for [__] his life up
it's gay to bang Hulk Hogan with a [__]
right
that's the kind of wisdom I need from my
mentor I'm so smart
whole thing and then he sent some of his
viewers over so I was joking with them
saying like is this what goes on on
Rumble
yeah I think so yeah
cool
you should live stream it hey Snicker
you should go to school and live stream
it that would be great content for
rumble
I'm so glad all these people found a
safe place in Rumble
clearly he's really uh hasn't moved on
he has his YouTube play buttons here
that's kind of a sad reminder of who he
used to be huh I mean throw those out if
you don't care right
but you do care and that's what's so sad
you've lost everything
you know
and you're dancing around with a gun
[Music]
my God man
you used to have a play button
100 000 potentially even a million here
and then one fateful evening sound
effect a bunch of dudes [__] on your
girlfriend it all changed
the truth is
it's okay that you felt inadequate
it's where you go from there right like
you can talk through those emotions
you can talk to your girlfriend and
maybe the girl that you loved who you
know
received enough semen in one day to
[__] grow a whole uh Army to invade
Ukraine
[Music]
coming but maybe that's maybe she's not
your Forever person and that's okay
maybe your guys's interests are not
aligned from everywhere in my room and I
I do think there's more fish in the sea
for you but you gotta you know your
inadequacies aside clearly you're in
your impotent or something or you can't
please a woman
but that's something you can work on
mm-hmm you know
if your penis is too small just give
killer head dude right
can make it you can make it work bro
and so I'm just saying is it too late
for snico
it might be
[Music]
might be
this is like this is a preview of Joker
too right here
this man is so [__] lost like look
like this man is alive
meltdown about the whole thing and then
he sent some of his viewers over so that
that is just wow
wow
I was joking with them saying like oh
you guys must just stopped the cuties
watch party over there it's Nico stream
right welcome Cox that kind of [__] I've
not seen this club that is actually I
mean
well
bro
shoot really [__] does he have a I
wonder if he's like
unwell
that was pretty psycho psycho thing I
just saw
like does he need an intervention you
know what I mean
you may need an intervention
none of my business I'm sure Andrew Tate
will have your best mental health uh
priorities in mind
you know what he needs
just a couple sips of beer oh that's
true it only takes one or two
rub some dirt in here
sneako will go to Andrew and be like yo
bro I'm feeling like kind of manic I'm
feeling like I don't know man I just
don't feel like myself stop being a
[__] no right oh you need to go out get
drunk and [__]
fast forward to snico dancing in his
room with a [__] handgun you people
are not thinking about the questions
people he wants to kill
yeah welcome to the new episode
uh here is snico asking his Discord for
a good response bro you're so inadequate
this is sad as [__] brother wow crit has
absolutely dismantled this poor guy and
I already has five million views after
20 hours how does he how does he come
back from this
I don't know and canceling you again
shaking your fist at the clouds I also
love that you treat this Discord server
like it's your PR team so you have them
work on your responses on Twitter
because you're not witty enough to come
up with anything on your own you have no
ability to Banter you can't insult
anyone anytime you're pushed all you
fall back on is one of three things soy
boy bot or NPC and that's it you never
deviate from this path which is ironic
because you're like literally a sheep
you have three programmed responses
you're like 100 he's like if you want to
talk about NPC it's like
but edutate NPC it's like bro you don't
have an an original thought in your head
don't you see
we need to blur this G fuel bro I can't
believe Chris drinking that [__] lead
I only drink gamer stuff
thank you
absolute worst character side character
in an MMO it's pathetic but
I'm getting sidetracked you love to be
super public about so was that it for
the Discord thing yeah pretty much yeah
it was just showing screenshots of
him asking for layups this year
he says scroll up I think you're cutting
off the top of the video
I'm not
no it's full I am [__] my little [__]
quick I need a response go to memes
everyone bro
dude
you are so sad
further proof that you don't have an
original thought in your head
ah it's fantastic I love to see these
guys just get absolutely clowned on by
the whole world here's Nico talking
about his favorite movie cuties
speaking out against our cuties last
night and it was it was pretty good it's
a pretty good movie I went in ready to
hate like everybody else I saw the cover
and it was I got clickbait so did you
you got clickbaited thing about cuties
is it's not an unrealistic film like yes
it shows children in a sexual way but
this is not unusual and
yes it shows children in a sexual way
but
and the people who are really mad about
this aren't gen Z imagine claiming
children in sexual positions is Click
bait yeah well anyway whatever so I I do
think he said it was his favorite movie
boom
oh that's the title of his video
Brave of him to put that out there
I didn't hear snico talking about the
time that uh his girlfriend basically
face was Noah's Ark and the endless
reign of bukaki
wow
you're a poet he recommends that
everyone should try it at some point for
some reason because this was imagine
imagine seeing the girl you love like
get [__] get [__] yeah I do I love
it yeah I love her I like how he goes he
goes get imagine the girl you love get
[__] like you bro you know she was
loving it
and listen I couldn't handle that I
would not want to see Ela you know
having sex with a bunch of dudes it's
not for me
and that's okay right seems like it's
maybe not for snico either it's not and
he learned that the hard way right
and um and that's okay you just gotta
move on bro oh there you go
what'd you find Olivia found
the receipt of him saying it's his yeah
it was in the Tweet he sent out
announcing the video here he is this is
good here's a picture of all of us and
it just says antidepressants boy you
need antipsychotics and I'm not saying
that to be funny I just saw a video of
you dancing around your room with the
handgun pictures of people you want to
kill
like you genuinely need to check in
and I say that with all the peace and
love in the world
also you should be kissing my [__]
dick I am the traditional I'm living the
traditional uh Trad lifestyle that you
would only dream of
just because I'm a little chubby no
[__] I've got kids I'm rich I've got a
wife that I've been with for 15 years
what's up [__]
what's up
living that Trad lifestyle you should be
kissing my feet and asking me how I did
it you're a conservative icon I am I
should be yeah why are you going to
Andrew Tate who's single as [__] by the
way a Loveless single [__] come talk to
me I'll teach you how to be a good
traditional male
okay let me tell you about gender roles
I'm serious man
here's a sneako making a confession
cuties here he is he tweeted this out
and actually he didn't even erase it I
made a confession in my new vid cuties
is my new favorite movie
you know that's a brave interesting
stance okay he removed it oh he's banned
[Applause]
oh God
Charlie is ready to meet him in battle
see when I did this all the all right
conservatives made like psycho um kill
you remember those I didn't even show
the gun
I was just saying I had a shotgun and
they all made like psycho kill montages
remember yeah they made you look I
looked cool so badass yeah I did
Charlotte did it in a pretty funny way
where he kind of fact checked the
sneaker a little bit and he didn't bring
out the guns to flex but he to like just
it's a location it's a low-key Flex
though let's be real of course but it's
the purpose but it's not directly the
purpose wait what's up about having a
handgun
it's not snico in his video kept
referring to his clips and Charlie
correctly I doesn't have a clip it's not
a clip it's called a magazine no he
doesn't even he's like a fake gun fan
that's what he that was the point he was
trying to make is like you don't even
there's no way worse than that yeah a
gun poser what you want to watch my
Clips watch my clips
watch my clips
you wanna oh you want me to watch your
Clips watch my clips
check in what Paul you're having a
mental health emergency and the people
in your life actually don't care about
you
you know what's interesting the people
in your life sneako are all as like
here's the thing
you are all so damaged that you think
it's normal that's the problem
you all have daddy issues
mommy issues
probably weren't loved weren't respected
your girlfriend was basically
[Music]
your girlfriend was basically like
a fire hose of of human semen and that
made you feel inadequate
and y'all think that's normal but it's
not the feeling you have you can feel
better if you seek treatment
you know
I'm telling you man you can
get better
and eventually if you play your cards
right you can live a traditional
lifestyle like me
[Music]
be in a loving relationship with kids in
a house
[Music]
two dogs
I will be your traditional male hero
that you so need and deserve
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
my Clips while threatening me here is
because during the stream I couldn't
watch him live because he just kept
shouting slurs so I said watch my Clips
to see what I was saying about you I had
to communicate via twitch clips and I'm
sorry to be that guy this is like the
grammar police of guns but he's a
[__] imbecile you absolute buffoon
what you have there is not close boom
these are mags they're mags not Clips I
mean that's fair if he's trying to flex
his guns and [__] he found a smooth way
to do it yeah you gotta you gotta say
the right [__] he's got a point salute
[__] dummy the same way that this is
also a MAG they're all mags stop saying
Clips you look [__] stupid here Kata
America is such an absolute hell hole
like I like Charlie there's no reason he
should have an Arsenal like and like I'm
not it's just America is so [__]
[__] it's like everybody's gotta own
three guns just in case the Civil War
erupts or some [__] well he's in Florida
too right yeah you never know that's it
you never know why you need to be armed
everybody's armed there so you better
have an arch little
yep
oh [__] am I wrong is anyone else
surprised Charlie has an arsenal
I'm I'm surprised yeah I it is insane
how easy it is and how many guns people
seem to have my best friend has a bunch
of guns I don't know why and he just
accidentally shot through his bedroom
floor he's lucky he didn't kill his mom
Jesus Jesus Christ more guns it makes
people more safe okay that's it what the
[__] now you want to see a real badass
who understands gun safety
here I am
step to me [__] that's what I
say
do you have your finger on the trigger
no it's not on this trigger it's not
loaded either by the way okay
good on both counts this is when I just
got it
I got this gun for home defense only
that's what shotguns are good for yeah
because I was scared and especially I
was living on a public Street then and
got swatted like a billion times so I
was like yo please if you step to me I'm
armed no I'm just kidding
not trying to have a shootout with the
police
but I would if I needed to that's all
I'm saying
and that's what makes me cool and badass
that's happening
but if I do feel like genuinely like I
need a gun for home defense because
there's so many because everyone else is
coming around you literally had people
like trying to break into your house I
think it's fairly reasonable and they're
all loaded I don't I wish they didn't
have guns you know then I could just
have a samurai sword something cool like
that
I'd love to defend my house with a
samurai sword but that's just not what
it is
yeah but there it is everyone's got to
have an arsenal
anyway sorry for the gun Anatomy lesson
he was very upset so he was threatening
to come shoot me beat me up all of that
because I hurt his feelings and go off
snap off you're doing it right
so there it is oh we didn't get to
finish watching this
say that I love my queen my queen
the first time as soon as I saw like
three pumps in I just got up and walked
can't do that I'm feeling traumatic
thoughts like seeing her with another
person it's a lot it's a lot but I think
it's something everybody should do just
bro hell no this is what like because
there's a lot of people being like Oh
don't don't King Shame or whatever the
the issue isn't that he has an unusual
Kink it's that he doesn't
and he's lying to himself about that in
fact it seems that it's clearly not okay
with it yeah three pumps and he was out
man it's so embarrassing Jesus but why
is he saying everyone should try it I
find that bizarre because he's lying to
himself because he can't handle the fact
that his like the fact that like his
girlfriend cheated on him in front of
him well apparently no yeah and it
wasn't like they went together
apparently he was meant to have sex with
another girls too right yeah it was
supposed to be like a group sex but he's
just he wasn't he wasn't secure enough
or confident enough or forever and he
had to bail which is fine right most
people don't have it in them to see that
that's more normal than not sure and um
I'd like to know why he thinks everyone
should try that once right after saying
it was traumatic like
in the same breath I mean Flash Forward
to him dancing in his in his living room
right yeah he handled it really well
turned into [__] Buffalo Bill from it
dude yeah
you know we call his uh he called his
his girlfriend a queen actually I heard
they started calling her the Lady of the
Lake afterwards because she was in a
[__] Lake of semen Jesus Christ so
she's a queen the queen of semen Lady of
the Lake yeah very nice King Arthur uh
reference there thank you yeah she was
the one that gave him Excalibur and by
Excalibur I mean lifelong trauma
like you're going for an ex-girlfriend
joke there Excalibur ex-girlfriend no
just lifelong well yeah you know it is
it's a little old-timey joke you
understand we got a little old time bee
all right let's keep going all different
flavors it's a lot but I think it's
something everybody should do just to
test I know you know what so my point
with this was I want to see the whole
thing damn
why is this the guy that's lecturing
everyone on their relationships [__]
on people's relation you're right I do
want to see the whole thing though
because I I find that so interesting it
is really like a villain origin story
when he watches girlfriend I'd be a
little wary about watching a not edited
clip from that no I've seen it it's
nothing bad that was like before he went
off off the rails that's the origin
story you know what I mean right that's
like when you know Joker got fired from
his clown gig like he hadn't gone
Church
yeah his girlfriend actually I heard
they call her the Mariana Trench
I'll let you use your imagination as to
why
[Music]
just covered
it's the deepest trench in the whole
world just
liquid boom so much weight and liquid
it's all up there on top
um
yes sir
oh here we got it thank you
so let's see so the the arrangements
goddamn it's loud
the Titleist Nico took his girl to a sex
party and he was not ready I'll say
Arrangements
the top comments is bro the Taliban
could kidnap me and torture me for
months and they couldn't get this out of
me that's so true you bro you should
have took this to the Grave man
made a big mistake and now wants
everyone to go through that trauma
because he effed up and doesn't want to
be the only one who let his girlfriend
get smashed
it's really not for everybody
it's really not
but uh he disagrees let's see what he
has to say this is awesome
there's not many people in the world
that you can just say whatever you want
about because they're so shitty Shanika
is one of those people
I love that
by the way clearly has a no sock or shoe
policy what are we trying to hit Wiki
feet everybody's got their toes out
straight toe bro
no shoes in the apartment
no socks I can respect that no socks
well the sock I don't know yeah I guess
I don't know should they come over to
sneakers house he's like bro you got to
take your socks off they're like what
I took my shoes off no no take your
socks off bro
okay I guess
the arrangements of our own
relationships like I can go and like
once in a while use a condom and like
you know one eye stands whatever and
then she can go on dates but she doesn't
have sex with them she just likes to be
taken how did you negotiate that out of
curiosity
[Laughter]
currently that's the arrangement it's
working pretty well but I thought like
that's not completely Fair like I gotta
do what I want so we we went to a couple
different uh orgies so so this came from
a place of equity he said it's not fair
so he was kind of a feminist King
in that sense
sex parties oh worse
I didn't participate though
yeah I mean
let's go all the way back was this
really just one year ago or was it
uploaded one year ago
uh let me because that would be so
insane like the timeline on that
all the way back so no no you are you
you're right naked [__] sword fight no
no what what are you around naked men
yeah
proven
sneakers around naked man
got him gay
hahaha
oh [__] yeah
I've been up to some weird [__] this man
been to a glow glory hole party
there's parties
we said Club a club yeah it's very
exclusive
there's a line outside the bathroom yeah
gay but not the [__]
right that was understood yeah yeah it's
to come you're right right sex stuff
um the original upload is from November
25th 2021. there you go this is just a
year ago a little over oh lead dude
this is a dark timeline for poor snico
just a year ago he was on top of the
world his own YouTube channel he can
even have sex with other girls with a
condom
then all of a sudden he wanted to be a
feminist King said his girlfriend is not
fair you need to be able to sleep with
other people to crash cut one year later
he's dancing in his apartment with a
[__] pistol in the list of people he
wants to kill
that's why he hates feminism feminism
ruined his life
[Music]
if his girlfriend would have just stayed
in the kitchen in the house where she
belonged and never got
you know
I can't wait
toys isn't that what he unironically
says
I remember I haven't watched it
um I think I remember when we last
talked about this
that's why I'm gonna watch the whole
thing I [__] love this clip man
and sneako if you are watching this I
just want you to know how little I
respect you and everything I'm saying is
actually
um
on one hand I respect you so little but
the other hand I do think that I could
be a I can save you
as a traditional male
gender roles and everything I'm CIS as
it gets brother
I've never been in the room with a naked
guy before ever
is it this as a cat I'm sis as [__]
brother is it a coincidence that the
original video is sponsored by
betterhelp it is
that's funny Avery just pointed it out
are you serious
it was brother wait this stream or
whatever the [__] they're on yeah yeah
this is just a highlight so the main wow
oh that is interesting
I mean that would be a good audience
[__] me
why do you know about the top floor
meet him stay down me and him did not go
to the top floor you've been there
before though I've never been to the top
floor
anyway when you went up there uh you
said something
to the nature of whatever happens
happens what yeah so so we go in there
with the mentality that whatever happens
inside that party it just stays at the
party like yeah and so I saw her
I've seen her [__] other men and it's
just like that was seen it yeah I saw
like so it sounds like she potentially
even went off and was just
well it sounds like that was the plan
that was the plan she was just you know
enjoying herself like a feminist queen
that you enabled her to be
God damn bro see I don't want to see
that
this video is giving me so much anxiety
I I wouldn't
I would not want to see my significant
other like that
and I just know that about myself right
literally right
I want to start from the beginning you
came uh because I want to get into all
that that's fantastic stuff so I wanted
to break this down like this because
this was imagine imagine seeing the girl
you love like get [__] get [__] did
you not do that before you went there
you know what I mean
that's a question to ask before you go
but okay we all make mistakes yeah I do
I love it yeah I love her I was about to
say I love this [__] I'm like no I may
not say that I love what a guy what a
gentleman my queen and you allowed the
love of your life to get [__] by
another man what happened to the others
I love that like he's he's found such
sympathetic ears to hear his problems
again he he goes on you are the company
you keep this guy's like yo I had this
really trap yo you're gay bro you're a
[__] cook idiot loser they're just
like shouting him down it's awesome yo
Bros I really want to come out to you
about something traumatic that happened
to me [__] gay [__] loser
I would never do that
it's awesome
I'm sis as [__] bro
the last time I was in the room with the
naked man was the day I was conceived
hahaha
that's it
even my children I say go in another
room that's gay
I said my sons goes dad can you wipe my
ass I say that's gay son wipe your own
ass
that's sis brother take what take it
from me the day I was conceived
either goes can you change Bruce's
diaper I say are you trying to turn me
gay are you trying to gay bait shame on
you want me to see my son's genitalia
what is wrong with him that is so wrong
are there rules to like how big the
[__] dick can be uh whatever happened
because if it's 10 inches it's not
happening
and so that's why I just don't do it
really
like he this man's going around next to
his girlfriend with the ruler
measuring the dicks that she's allowed
to have sex with jeez I wouldn't tell
God this [__]
oh my God I think he I think he was
actually traumatized and I think he
thinks that by sharing it he will normal
try to feel normal or normalize or find
sympathy or try to find therapy in it
and I think the opposite happened for
him
clearly
yeah he should have died with this you
should have took this one with the grave
bro
better help between you and better help
bro that's it
proud dog you shouldn't even be [__]
random women with 10.
what she be doing with 10 then you
should be keeping that [__] to yourself
what dude take it to the circus I don't
know so can she enjoy it like what if
she's enjoying it too much that's the
thing like like it's like she's moaning
pretty loud like I don't know
embarrassing
it's just like crazy that you put this
out there another top comment says you
can clearly see the moment when his
facial expression changes from someone
who thought the story was going to make
him look cool to oh [__] this makes me
look like the complete opposite what I
thought like the biggest and especially
in his crew like I I'm taught like I'm
tolerant and I understand I'm
sympathetic to different people and
different interests his friends are not
you know
yeah I wonder what Tate would say about
this or uh fresh and fit they'd Blame
the Girl
they'd probably blame her
you know true
so all right so we we want it okay hold
on we went on two different occasions
the first time crazy the first time as
soon as I saw like three pumps in I just
got up and walked out I'm just like I
can't I can't do that that is literally
of you one two and
so we were supposed to swap another
couple but I didn't like I wasn't really
[__] with his girl and but us
swingers that's not really a orgy party
no sir
it was an ugly girl to take
I feel like this is like a conversation
that nobody's supposed to see
you're like a fly on the wall of like a
frat house that of some cursed
conversation that everybody just wants
to forget ever happened
yet here it is for all of us to watch
credible
who proposed it was that your solution
to like trying
I think it was both of our ideas we saw
something in that show sex life on
Netflix like they went to a swinger
party like oh we could do that and
especially because like like I we do
threesomes all the time and she's not
even that bisexual so it's like she's I
kind of feel like she's putting on a
show a little bit so I'm like if I'm
able to go and have one I stand to be
have an open relationship and she can
only go on dates this is a place where
she can exercise the open relationship
like if it should be she's not going
she's just going on dates
okay whatever side note it's Chad is
saying is the dude on the left ever
going to rub in that lotion it has been
making me a little angry what the [__]
is going on with his foot dude he has
put lotion on it but he didn't he's just
a little rub it in is that what it is
the other leg he's I like forgot it's
sitting there he's so enamored but you
know what he did he did it to traumatize
Nico because it looks like the load that
was on his girlfriend's face he's like I
can't remind him right now I need to
stop bro can you can you please rub that
lotion it's giving me PTSD
fair that she can take other dick if I'm
[__] another [__]
that's balance
it's gonna happen I might as well see it
supervise it make sure everything's okay
what no you didn't have to jump today
right now it's worse if I if she happens
behind my back like I don't want it it's
not but y'all both knowing that it's
happening so it never behind your back
anymore you just gotta know I gotta see
it you don't need to be literally in
front of you it was literally like this
far away from me
[Laughter]
and I was just like not [__] with it
and I saw her and she was like ah I was
like [__] that I just left the room and
then she left too like luckily I thought
she was gonna steal her dog why you
leave alone but I couldn't like it was I
was literally having PTSD watching that
I was like having war flash like I just
thought I could not do it could not
this dude's trying to be Alpha on the
internet right now
you know
holy [__] which is interesting when you
consider everything that he's just
sitting there like like the setting is
actually quite interesting like he's not
able to have sex with
the girl he's meant to and he's just
sitting there watching his girlfriend
get railed and moan and Fletcher and
then he just gets up and leaves and then
he goes on this podcast and tells
everybody about it I'm wondering
I'm wondering if the ears that heard
this story for the first time were more
sympathetic and caring and asked
questions that would maybe provoke like
actual growing and learning I wonder
where we would be today
that was the moment this is where it all
started this is the villain the villain
uh the Zim fall in the Nevada I hate
women this is yeah exactly we would be a
different timeline completely yeah I
like how his homie like doesn't have his
back in any way at first he goes here
crazy and then when he goes I got up
he's like bro you're killing the mood
like you can't make any good it's like
you [__] up dude it doesn't matter
like missionary
[Music]
I'm worried about this episode getting
yellow by the way we've been very
descriptive and graphic with a lot of
sexual stuff uh he just said missionary
that's not that bad talking about the
Marianas Trench filled with semen that's
like a hypothetical it's not a real
secret I'm just saying I'm a little
nervous about it we might we might get
started staring at her like in her eyes
like deep eye contact oh deep eye
contact yeah
[Applause]
eye contact
deep eye contact
oh this is the most watched part deep
eye contact and she says I want you to
[__] me
oh brother
he's like laying his soul out this is
like the most vulnerable a person's ever
been on camera
would have told by this
what love uh they're funny they're just
[__] railing because yeah this man is
like this is not cool in their world
this is like insane like he's supposed
to [__] other girls not watch his girl
get [__]
they're like in her eyes like deep eye
contact
[Laughter]
oh [__]
wow makes me sad you're sad for him yeah
in that moment I mean he's turned into
someone I'm not sad for well at that
moment he was we could have saved it
right if he was on our show
on age three
yeah if it was into this this would have
been fine like if he was saying yeah I
love that [__] yeah but him being so
uncomfortable makes this so cringy it's
hard to listen to it
right right it's like he
the way he described it to by the way
thank you for the subs peanut butter and
fika I think it says FICA I can't see
the end of it
the way he notices everything right you
know the eye contact she grabs his junk
and pulls it in her
I love that his latest Instagram post
he's in like Dubai and he's like his
caption as the West has fallen I'm sure
they're really open-minded about this
kind of stuff over there the West is
here let me pull that up the West has
fallen I'm tried as [__] bro you know I
know you ain't talking about me
I know you ain't talking about me Adidas
under your thing what do you call that
outfit
um I'm not sure actually Lena do you
know
no she's not here
probably not a robe
yeah the West is falling he says what
about the West is falling
the only thing you want to talk about
the westfalling I think that dude
dropped um
dropped the big one over Nagasaki AKA
your girl's face
the West won the war that day my friend
bro I'm tried as [__] you say I'm the
bad guy but I'm tried as [__] so how is
the West falling
you know
like this the toes yeah straight up if
the toes ever curl I think I saw a
little there was a little arch in the
toe
he noticed all the details okay so let
me backtrack
before before you AO so so this is
outside so um I'm nervous as [__] like
I'm like dude yo there's bad people here
let me let me all right that party was
like I'm getting nervous
I'm literally had PTSD about this like I
had bad dreams about this for like a
week like I didn't know that's really
bad he's having bad dreams about it
that's genuinely
some real trauma there dude
call me Travis because I'm the Trad guy
or Travis
you can call me Travis
CIS as [__]
they call me
I'm sorry to say this if it's offensive
is [__] an offensive word or not like
in the terms of Tran well CIS just means
you identify no but I'm saying because
[__] is a bad word so you can call me
[__] Ethan
but like in the traditional in the
traditional Series yeah it seems kind of
interesting right sis Ethan [__] Ethan
double meaning it's a double meaning
you know oh he rubbed it in what a king
thank you Legend
oh I was [__] up salmon so we showed
up to the swinger party everything and
everybody like for they're having drinks
and then all of a sudden snap everyone's
naked and then they're [__] on the
floor on the bed he was there there's
like 40 people there's like there's like
maybe maybe 30 30 to 40 people
15 couples where y'all at in a ball yeah
15 couples 30 balls yeah where are y'all
a hotel room that many people having sex
30 people how many balls did he say he
said 30 15 dudes 30 balls yeah at the
[__] Harlem Globetrotters in there
they're dunking all over his girl's face
dude
that's a good enough that's a good
analogy they were dunking on him and
[__]
he sneakers just sitting there watching
his girl get railed and the guy next to
him is just like
oh my doing all the crazy jump shots
oh damn
sister oh so yeah the sister snap like
sis
Ethan my sister sister snapped
it's a small room yeah it's not even
that it's like a suite a hotel suite
um it's not very big it's not a very big
place not for real okay what the [__]
this is like so seedy and weird this
setting he's talking about
you probably couldn't even walk by
without brushing dicks with another dude
sounds like they're pretty crowded
Embassy Suites or something like that
getting through that room is like
walking through a car wash
that's good
just dicks swinging everywhere and stuff
being sprayed on you and blown
it's good
like anxious like I don't want to do
this and so we go alone in the bathroom
and she's like helping me out like
calming me down and then we start doing
our thing in the bathroom the door and
then the doors open people come and
start watching this other couple comes
in hold on hold on
this dude could even finish with the
lotion he's just so floored his white
his leg is just White
this couple comes in they start watching
and then I hear his girl say to the
boyfriend like lick her [__] and so
while I'm like hitting it from the back
he lays down on the floor and starts
licking her but think about like the
logistics of that dick is that close
think of the exact thing about the
logistics like his head is like under
it's like six inches like his eyebrows
are like tickling the bottom and I have
to like move like go like that so I
don't make contact because this is
eyebrows bro I don't think that's really
the setting to be homophobic
like you kind of just got to be cool
being around
other dudes dicks if you're in that room
you know okay
you just got I think you have to be a
little
you know what's the chance his dick
didn't rub up on another dude's deck
not that there's a problem with that but
come on
now's not the time to act like
no homo
no homo my dick touched another dude's
dick no homo though
his eyelashes were tickling my balls no
homo
I am not gay uh this person says Ethan
can you try to say my name and give me a
shout out
Fatima
Fatima that's either fatuma uh Fatima
they pronounce fatuma it's Mexican I can
tell because the donation
Fatima
vadima
probably not that
but congratulations on the new job
I'm like here with it like I'm trying to
not touch his head and he he was
completely okay with it like and you
were too I was I'm like here I'm like
trying I'm joking though right I stopped
I stopped like I'm like I can't this is
so funny he's like being careful that
his homies don't think he's gay like you
of course you were fine with it dude
you're in a room with 30 people and
that's it God bless you know what I mean
my dick did fall into his mouth no homo
there was like five penises brushing on
me at a time no homo
and this is logistically this is not
going to work and so then yeah and then
she asked me like um from behind you he
crawled from like underneath like he
like
between both legs well yeah we're
standing up I'm hitting from the back
and then he goes underneath no no no it
was his body
to be honest
I think he got his nuts touched by
another guy I think no questions
no question casualty of war and and
that's it you're in a room you know this
is not the setting to be like no homo
yeah like you there's homo homo yes homo
but like in the best way collateral
damage or it's not but like it doesn't
mean you're gay just because your nuts
rubbed in other dudes
right
it just means that
you're maybe more comfortable with
you're just somewhere on the Spectrum
right
that dude was definitely licking his
balls right I think so yeah but I guess
and that's fine dude that probably you
know felt great
and that scared him a little that it
felt so good
you know
well no because it was blocked by like
oh you're [__] what genuinely why do
you think he's telling the story
like genuinely genuinely what was he
thinking uh I the architect says this
guy was getting licked up for sure for
sure
which is cool I think like you said at
the start I think he went into this
thinking this was going to make him
sound cool he I don't think he was
expecting the reaction that he's getting
from his buddies
that a dude was licking his ball sack
you know
hey
he's like all right I'm getting all my
most homophobic friends together all
right guys so yeah dude was licking my
ball sack the other day
both [__] yeah yeah so you make eye
contact with your [__]
yeah I'm like nah I started thinking
about that I'm like I can't do it I
can't do it I can't do it so that's too
gay bro it's too gay it's too gay I
can't do it so you're in a hotel room
with like 30 40 people yeah that you've
never met your girl is calming you down
hey sneako chill yeah some people walk
in and action just starts what's
happening outside this hotel is
everybody [__] hard everybody so we
owe the bathroom have privacy everybody
else is already [__] on the bedroom
like yo this is whoa and they found you
out of there and no although after we
start doing the thing like someone
opened the door and then like people
watching like yeah yeah and then yeah
bathroom sex is crazy yeah okay so then
what is privacy so then then we go into
the room like a couple like all right
and I guess it is yeah it sure seemed
like a standout that in this story then
the orgy out there yeah
I think is one of those things where
he's just trying to contribute at this
point okay it's like what do you say how
could you relate yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's crazy like bro bathroom sex great
there's people [__] on the fan on the
roof
[Music]
he's like yeah he was spinning around
his dick with just slapping people in
the face he's like yeah your bathrooms
have toilets yeah
that's right coconuts and Barbados
man it is Tuesday or Wednesday sorry
man it is Wednesday
yo those sandwiches here Sam this
what happened
Firehouse original I don't think it was
it I think the delivery driver canceled
on us and had to be reassigned I hate
when that happens yeah
why does that have four times too far
and they're like I don't want it
did you can they see the tip that you
leave
I don't think they see it until after
the delivery
because that'd be crazy right if they
just this would have been a big order
though so you'd assume a big tip I don't
know how much did we tip him Sam
percent
that's a good tip
so I got this girl no no no no you're
good you're good what's happening she's
I don't know yo I'm just not and my
girl's right here and she's like and I'm
like oh yo I'm like like feeling
traumatic thoughts like seeing her with
another person it's a lot it's a lot but
I think it's something everybody should
do just to test I know you know what you
know what no this is the part I'm really
interested in this is why we're here
why should everybody do this after that
after that lovely prescription so
anyways you all should try I'm I'm
loving this I'm with Ethan it's rare
that you have someone so evil that
produces something that's cringe so I'm
all in no this this dude I this clip is
[__] like my favorite kind of content
you can ever find yeah I'm gonna watch
this whole goddamn video every second of
it and you know what
it's Nico went a lot through a lot to
get this clip out to the world so I
think yeah we should have bought him
yeah hey snico if you're watching
I don't want to give you any trauma but
just this is just imagine I'm your
girlfriend and this is one of the
monster [__] that
penetrator
um
what do we think about the fire
Firehouse it's a little sweet which
throws me off by sweet mm-hmm
interesting what's sweet in there
it's a big sandwich
is it the ham must be the ham
maybe let's play the video while you eat
so that
I said the same [__] before
bro like you don't want to be that
couple yeah
why you don't want to be one couple it's
a sex party whatever happens there it
happens
I think you should I think you should go
through that trauma no I think everyone
should go to that say that
this is the point this is this is the
reason you go to sex parties with the
girl like I think everyone should go
fight in the trenches and watch their
best friends die
what other traumish people experience
Nico
I think everybody should be an altar boy
oh boy
we need to put them in a hotel room you
can play the Subway sandwich close
enough
all right
I need Ambience you were so dedicated to
authenticity last time and now you're
willing to just play Subway music over
there well it's not planned it's
improvised
sorry Dad
I just think that's a little
disrespectful to Zach's hard work
you can play something else if you want
ah [__] it
[Laughter]
excellent sandwich
yeah mine's mine's pretty good pretty
good I like it what'd you guys get
I didn't get anything you didn't get
anything done
hey shortly before the show and they
didn't they're one of those sub places
that they have a veggie option and it's
just like the shittiest like
little here's some here's some tomato
slices and some iceberg lettuce I got
you
we got Pastrami and roast beef pastrami
yeah
what do you guys got
I got a turkey and ham
I got the same as Zach and Ian we all
got the hook and ladder this is amazing
uh it's turkey ham
what else is on here tomatoes lettuce
onions uh they have this like sweet
sauce that goes on it that's bomb
Firehouse
you know we are at three minutes we
could uh
we could maybe just wrap up the show
three hours all right let's just say
three minutes three hours putting them
for three hours
why would I do that when I still have
time to get canceled
right there's that there's that and also
you can force the audience to listen to
you too
they can mute it
[Laughter]
um
after I finish this we'll finish the
video
alrighty
I just want sneako to tune in here and
be really confused
it doesn't have access to YouTube
anymore unfortunately
it's bound can't even watch it I can
watch videos yeah
okay I'll just play it actually that's
fair
Ian got me all hyped up with that
you got to see if this is the person
that you actually want to be with
because if you enjoy sex with somebody
more if there's somebody you're more
attracted to or if you're not on the
same page sexually then it's not going
to be a good time but if you can go
through that experience like with your
partner and like you still it was it
feels stronger afterwards like after all
that everything like we everything was
like better to be honest holy [__]
this man is in denial
bro just made our relationship so much
stronger
oh yeah where is she
she's random hotel room yeah she's in
the bathroom still rumor is she's still
that train is still running today
are you still chilling I mean you know
what that sounds fun you see but you
still cheat though less so even after
that it's not stealing if it's open
relationship
after that you still [__] other women so
what are we talking about actually no
it's been a while it's been a while like
the only time has been like just three
Sundays but you still did it though
threesomes though I mean like not
without I know but you're the point
you're making is that it's so traumatic
that it actually brought us closer
together because you can't it was I'm
talking just about the traumatic Parts
it was a lot of it was really fun I
don't want you to reopen this obvious
wound but like what what does that feel
like nah it's okay it felt like somebody
was like taking something for me like
someone was violating my property that's
what it felt like I felt like getting
robbed like right in front of me like
that's what oh that's not the best way
to put that is it no no
oops
I gotta watch myself up that's tragic
Ethan just walked out and just mumbled
he just mumbled as he was walking uh I
gotta clean myself up that's that's
funny that's probably exactly what
sneako said and he when he walked up oh
hell oh
[Music]
he said he said snigo said uh have a
good night
have a good night
all right that was quick all right yeah
I just need to what I just need to clean
my hands it was kind of getting kind of
gnarly
so um
your property huh
that's an interesting way to put it in
it
I think he might just be saying that to
look tough and cool but
the damage happened in his own heart and
soul let's be real
but well done sir good um good save
but yeah it's like I don't want it why
am I looking does I don't take any
enjoyment from that a lot of guys there
do a lot of the guys there I think are
bisexual a lot of the guys are into that
if you can lay in between some like
dudes [__] ass cheeks you got to be
answer that a little bit like that's
what I said
foreign
it's funny that he's doubting that
[Laughter]
like bro
it doesn't mean you're gay it just means
you're comfortable
having your balls in another dude's
mouth
chilling bro at one point I was like so
later on after the whole traumatic Hotel
incident we're laying on the floor she's
riding me and then I I have my eyes
closed she's right I open my eyes and
there's just dicks like trying to point
at her head like trying to get an angle
like trying to get her to suck like was
she the baddest one in here yeah my
question is this why are you there then
you guys are just having sex
do you not expect anyone there to like
do the Mount Rushmore Cox in her face
that's that's what it that's what goes
down there brother
because it's like kind of like DMV
for these parties now and I've never
felt the urge to like [__] another [__]
I've been like we've been we went to two
that night and then we went to two like
two nights ago
in the same night
you
seems a little [__]
screw you
to go to two orgies in the same night
like holy [__]
sounds like you needed more dick
do you think maybe it was the girl that
wanted to go and he's just saying I was
the one that wanted to go and that is
where all this insecurities coming from
like his girl wanted to go 100 I think
she was the driving force behind this
yeah and he's trying to claim claim it
as his idea
she sounds like she had a blast so yeah
yeah she was in her element
right
mm-hmm
yeah to another one we went to another
one like two weeks later yeah
proposing this is you or both of us both
of us yeah he's lying he's lying he just
had the most dramatic experience of his
life and they go to another one two
weeks later
stop it
just tell her it hurts your feelings
both of us it was like another she does
she feel the same way when you're
[__] somebody else in front of her
nah she likes it she likes watching it
yeah but I don't I don't even we've been
to four I've never [__] somebody else
at one of these parties so what so why
are you so why not how did she know she
likes it she ain't I've seen you do it
no she she seen me do it threesomes many
times but like not at a party
okay so I'm kind of confused if if she
if she's okay with you [__] other
women but you're not okay with her
[__] that's that's my problem like at
that point I realized like that's why I
think everyone should do it that's toxic
masculinity like I should be able to get
past that
oh wait what that's crazy what is it who
is this well King yeah it sounds like a
super like roundabout like interesting
form of thinking that just led him to
the wrong place possibly like I think
I think he doesn't it's it's okay that
he didn't want to participate yeah
monogamy is not toxic yeah no not at all
I think it was a girl [__] scrambled
his brain yeah
yeah how did you go from saying toxic
masculinity to
dancing in your room with a revolver I
mean he doesn't he's using that phrase
but given the context but that's like a
woke phrase
I find it interesting that he's saying
he needs to get rid of it
I thought these guys wanted to toxic
masculinity well the whole thing is that
he supposedly changed after this right
I don't think he was quite so red red
pilled at the time
not [__] your girl it's just not it's a
sex party bro it's normal it's just sex
bro it's a party with the cop like if
she wants to [__] somebody else
no with condoms not [__] so but they
all are they switching condoms or like
just one one you switch condoms you
switch condoms wait what no you don't no
like no like you if different people use
different condoms
you sure yes he sure is crazy yeah
[__] anybody at these parties no what
you're saying is you willingly hold
hands walk girl into [__] and go well
that's not the only thing that happened
like the first time was three dude he's
getting
eviscerated by his friends right now
you're telling me
you hold her hand the woman you love
walk her into a party where she gets
[__] by a bunch of dudes and you sit
there and watch
that's a [__] that's literally what a
cuck is they brought on another dude in
from uh from the other room
yeah dude people coming off the street
being like what
did you hear what this guy just does
everybody piling on oh my God strangers
neighbors that's so great three pumps on
them like I can't do it like this is too
much she's like oh okay look at that
room how they're all kind of like
interrogating him
you can see it in the body language
so why if you keep you keep going back
but you're not [__] nobody so okay we
went we well okay so it's more than just
that like sometimes I'll be [__] her
and then like women will slide in and
start sucking her titty and stuff like
that like some girl will like grab me
too or like some girls started licking
like walls so you like that yeah like
most like having multiple women like
four women that's that's pretty dope but
my point is why not just set that why
not let that be the extent of y'all's
relationship because that's what I want
and like she's she likes that too but
like that's not okay you know it's for
her pleasure as well she like likes dick
you know she likes other [__] dicks
she likes penis period
what I'm saying is she specifically want
other penises I mean she can go without
it like after the first party when I
said like yo listen listen
oh my god dude these guys
go without it he's so funny he's like no
you're not hearing me she wants to [__]
other people
you won't admit it
you didn't have to like she's like I
don't know it's okay we don't need to do
this anymore okay so that's what I'm
saying so why why go back yeah because
okay the second time which is two days
ago like it wasn't as bad it wasn't I
thought it was crazy yeah so you'll see
you're you're opening up more to this
I'm I'm less traumatized now yeah and
eventually like those people see like yo
I talked to this one old couple they're
both doctors and they show up to all
these parties that go like on trips and
everything and I've seen his wife get
slutted the [__] out in front of his
eyes like like choking and everything
like smacked around he's just watching
like yeah and then afterwards they go
home they're in the car and everything's
fine and I'm like how lights that though
he said he didn't like it at first
though he said he didn't like it at
first
somebody else makes your girl that's
tough no that was the big thing with the
first time like he smacked the [__] out
of her and I felt pain like oh God it
was loud and you could legally smack the
[__] out of him
yeah I know but he's smacked wait he's
so much slapped his girlfriend
did I miss hear that yeah I I thought
you're talking about that other doctor
couple but
I think he did right holy [__]
um yeah
you know they say the thing same thing
about war they say the first time you
see someone killed is traumatic
But as time goes on you kind of just get
used to seeing Mayhem Blood and Guts
around you and just being terrified all
the time
I think it's a lot like that samiko
well there it is this is the alpha on
the internet guys
dude now with all that
said and done this comment is just
amazing the Taliban could kidnap me and
torture me for months and they couldn't
get this out of me
and he just served it up on a platter
I love that
yeah
hearing this breaks my [__] heart
every time he goes deeper and deeper the
knife goes into my heart this was brutal
to sit through absolutely brutal
now this dude's trying to be an alpha
male
Sigma grind set rule 420. watch your
girlfriend get bukaki to traumatize
yourself because as top G always says
trauma is what builds men
that's super good that's beautiful he
does recommend him for everybody
this man was hurt on a metaphysical
level
oh [__]
this man has lived my worst nightmare
publicly and it's okay talk and it's
okay talking about publicly
there it is
so
I think it's some interesting context
into snico's psyche what do you guys
think
[Applause]
thanks for sharing that thanks for being
so vulnerable with us
yep
you think I moved up on his hit list
from that I was on the bottom you were
on the bottom right we might get go up a
couple that'd be great I'm down to be on
the tier list you're going up in the uh
Charlie was like a bullseye as long as
at the top so yeah you can't let that
stand moist got a circle maybe you'll
get another another shape oh yeah
fun at the top is it because Andrew Tate
hates him so much because he burned him
in that debate like what it's probably I
just think a lot of people on that side
fear Hassan because you know he's not
the tradition of what they're trying to
say they say leftists are soft and [__]
I am traditional
more than Hassan more than Hassan yeah
I'm traditional as [__]
I don't know if I mentioned that right
yeah
I'm [__] as [__] bro my sister Ethan
yeah sometimes I've been around dudes
that are wearing like muscle tees and I
tell them to put on a shirt that's
[__] gay
because I don't want to see their arms
shit's hot as hell I mean okay
yeah dude
that's right
mm-hmm
so the other thing we were supposed to
talk about was the milk Boys in Israel
but we've been going for a lot how long
we've been going there for three hours
and 10 minutes and uh yeah that there's
no like that's like an hour and a half
video you think you're gonna end up
watching the whole thing so so we can
watch it with Ela on Friday and that's
pretty good yeah
you know
today I feel uh gay
wow
that one always gets me
again
today I feel uh gay
that's the best thing to ever
well I guess that's it huh so if you see
snakeo just you know
give him a hug give him a hug yeah the
man is dead
salute him he might be armed though not
your fault and actually I mean he is
like
severely on the Neo-Nazi train now right
wasn't he like I think he's got to be
anti-semitic he was running around with
uh Nick Fuentes and yeah yeah like he's
got it you know
maybe just a pat on the shoulder right
maybe not a hoe just like a it's gonna
be all right buddy all right I don't
know you could care about him on a a
caring glitch human level right maybe it
was a Jewish orgy that's that's why he's
so interesting just a bunch of juice
[__] through sheets
that'd probably be better for him just a
dick I mean that's not that that's not
that gay yeah
answer me this what's more gay
sucking a dude off with him all there in
front of you or sucking him off through
a sheet where all you see is the dick
and nothing else
yeah I mean the sheet makes it not gay
it's not gay it's almost not gay at all
yeah
clearly Jewish glory hole they call it
because like of the body mass how much
is the dick really
one personally nothing five percent bro
you got a hog
because if I weigh 230 what's five
percent of 230
calculating I have like a 10 pound
calculator
230. that ain't healthy bro I think
that's called elephantitis
11.5 pounds
heavy that's like a that'll win you an
award at the carnival right that's the
juicer dude geez that's a juicer
that's like a large turkey
damn
yeah all right we're also um apparently
the uh it's been happening for a while
and slowly getting worse the uh a little
bit of crackle oh no sneaking into the
audio so um thank you guys everybody
it's been a joy it's been a treat
it's been good times been some bad times
but some laughs some some tears
it's all happened here on the H3 podcast
live
that's our show for today thank you to
all the lovely people
um our we'll be here tomorrow morning as
usual for leftovers
with the great Hassan [__]
got big news who famously said blank
deserved blank
shout out and I gotta say
and the way he meant it
[Music]
makes a lot of sense he's not wrong
reasonable take it's a it's the it's the
result of Our Own
shitty policies
our own shitty blank yeah the plane did
it everybody saw it
I got your back brother
absolutely right on that one
should I hit the button
whatever
I felt like oh
I felt like that was like
a pop almost like a popular kind of
obvious take is that it was a result of
our foreign policy uh yeah like it's not
that crazy I guess it's the way he said
it
[Music]
huh how do we get on this one I said
because Hassan famously said
Hassan
won a word for best cheddar
does it matter that
the person that gave him the awards like
his bestie you think it was corrupt no
cutie Cinderella
who I have no Pro
who I we'll see you see you tomorrow
have a good night
foreign